ASSEMBLY WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE. CHAIRED
WARNER GARCIA. AND WE'RE GOING
TO GET STARTED AS A SUB
COMMITTEE BUT THERE ARE A
HANDFUL OF HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS
THAT WE NEED TO REVIEW BEFORE
WE GET INTO THE SUBSTANCE OF
OUR HEARING- WELCOME TO THE
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE BILL
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE. I
WILL BEGIN BY SHARING A FEW
NOTES ABOUT THE LOGISTICS OF
OUR HEARING TODAY. THE STEPS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO HELP
PRESERVE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE AND TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
TAXES. TO THIS DISCUSSION. DUE
TO THE ONGOING PANDEMIC WE ARE
LIMITING THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT CAN. BE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT IN THE
HEARING ROOM TODAY. TO ENSURE
MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA AND PUBLIC
HAVE ACCESS TO OUR PROCEEDINGS
TODAY WE ARE ENSURING THERE ARE
MULTIPLE WAYS TO OBSERVE. AND
PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING.
TESTIMONY CAN BE PROVIDED IN
PERSON VIA THE PHONE OR VIA
TELECONFERENCE AT TO REMOTE
LOCATIONS ONE INSIDE THE
CAPITOL AND ONE ON THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS. EVERYONE IN THE
CAPITAL MUST WEAR MASKS THIS
INCLUDES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. AT THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM AND AT THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. LIKEWISE EVERYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM OR THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATIONS IS
REQUIRED TO PRACTICE SOCIAL
DISTANCING. GIVEN THAT A NUMBER
OF WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION TO THE BILLS ON THE
AGENDA WILL BE JOINING US.
REMOTELY WE ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
BEAR WITH US IF WE NEED TO WORK
THROUGH ANY TECHNICAL ISSUES.
FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM WE
ARE REQUIRING PHYSICAL DISTANCE
PLEASE FOLLOW THE DIRECTIONS OF
OUR SERGEANTS AND POSTED
GUIDANCE. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY. ON A BILL I WILL
ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC NOT TO TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO ABSORB
PHYSICAL DISTANCING WHEN
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. IN ADDITION
TO BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM WE MAY.
ALSO HAVE BILL WITNESSES MAKING
USE OF THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS THESE
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS FOR THIS HEARING IS
LOCATED IN ROOM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREENS IN THE
ROOM SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH THE
TESTIMONY LIVE AND ASK
QUESTIONS OF THESE WITNESSES.
THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT DELAY FOR
THE STREAM FROM THE WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM SO
PLEASE BE PATIENT. WE WILL ALSO
BE USING MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANYONE
CAN TESTIFY ON THE BILL. THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO.
AGAIN THE NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE. ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. THIS
CALL WITH THE AUTHOR THE BILL
YOU PLAN TO TESTIFY ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOUR SUPPORT. OR OPPOSE
A BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IF
YOU'RE CALLING HIM PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST. AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
ISSUES PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED
THAT IF YOU ARE A ME WITNESSES
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL. YOU WILL
REMAIN ON A LIFELINE I WILL
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED ON TO SPEAK AGAIN.
IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATOR PHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
SIX. AND COMMITTEE STAFF WILL
BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP. I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. FOR
EACH BUILT THERE COULD BE UP TO
TWO MAIN WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND TWO MAIN WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THESE WITNESSES.
HAVE BEEN MADE KNOWN TO THE
COMMITTEE IN ADVANCE. OF THE
HEARING WHICH WITNESS WILL BE
UP FIRST AND THEN OF COURSE
THERE TWO MINUTE. ALLOCATION
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ONLY. A ADDITIONAL
DETAIL YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE ABOUT YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL SHOULD BE SUBMITTED IN
WRITING TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO MINDFUL
AND RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS WILL FACE. FOR
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE-
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND TO
A ROLL CALL ASK A QUESTION
PROVIDE COMMENT. PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND AND TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONE IT IS YOUR TURN TO
SPEAK. IF YOUR PRESENT A BILL
TO THE COMMITTEE PLEASE PRESENT
MICROPHONE AT THE WITNESS TABLE-
AGENDA WE HAVE- A BILL THAT HAS
BEEN PULLED AB. FIVE THREE FOUR
HAS BEEN PULLED AND- COULD SET.
I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT A. B.
FIVE THREE FOUR BY SUMMER BONTA
HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR
AND WILL NOT BE HERE TODAY IT
IS. ELIGIBLE TO BE HEARD AT OUR
NEXT HEARING ALSO THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE ON CONSENT AB EIGHT
SEVEN EIGHT. SB SIX THREE AB
THREE ONE FIVE A. B. SIX NINE
TWO AND A. B. EIGHT ONE SEVEN-
WE WOULD NORMALLY TRY TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM T THIS TIME
WE HAVE. NOT ENOUGH MEMBERS- WE
MAY BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
AND SO BEFORE WE DO THAT WE
HAVE TO ADOPT BE A COMMITTEE
RULES- SCISSORS THIS IS OUR
FIRST BILL HEARING OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO LET'S SAY
SAID SHE WANTED TO DROP
COMMITTEE ROLES IS RECALLS A
ROLL COUPLE WITH THE MAJORITY
OF THE COMMITTEE IN FAVOR.
ANYONE HAS ANY QUESTIONS PLEASE
ASK THEM NOW IF NOT I WILL TAKE
A MOTION- OR WE CAN'T BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM. BUT
WE'RE GOING THROUGH THE
FORMALITIES HERE OKAY- WE DO
HAVE A BILL. AUTHOR HERE ND SO
WHAT WE'LL ASK. HER TO COME.
FORWARD AND PRESENT A BILL. YES
THIS IS. THAT MEANS. OR GET.
FOR MORE. GOOD AFTERNOON YEAH.
THEY DR. THE AB WORKING
GENERATE FUNDING. OKAY
EDUCATION. WELL. MR DON'T.
EIGHT DUCK IN UPLAND GAME BIRD
STAMPS REQUIRED TO HUNT
WATERFOWL AND UPLAND GAME BIRDS.
SB SIX FOURTEEN ALSO REQUIRES
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY AND
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY OR THE
SPENDING OF THE FUNDS COLLECTED
VIA THE UPLAND GAME BIRD STAMP.
IN LINE WITH CURRENT PRACTICES
FOR THE STATE DUCK STAMP. LACK
OF AVAILABLE NOW NESTING COVER
ESPECIALLY IN AGRICULTURAL
AREAS LIKE THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY RICE GROWING REGION. IS
A SIGNIFICANT LIMITING FACTOR
FOR BREEDING WATER FELL AND
OTHER GROUND NESTING BIRDS. THE
NESTING BIRD PROGRAM IS
FLEXIBLE ENOUGH TO MEET
CALIFORNIA GROWERS NEEDS AS
FUNDS CAN BE USED TO PLANT
COVER CROPS. ENHANCE EXISTING
NESTING BIRD HABITAT OR
ESTABLISHED NESTING COVER ON
THE LANDS THAT ARE FOLLOWED
UNDER DIFFERENT PROGRAMS. SB
SIX FOURTEEN IS A RESOURCE
GENERATING CONSERVATION
MEASURES THAT WILL COMPLEMENT
OUR STATEWIDE GOALS FOR CARBON
SEQUESTRATION. IMPROVING AIR
QUALITY THE PROTECTION OF OUR
WATER FILL SPECIES. THE BILL
HAS RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION
ENJOYS WIDESPREAD SUPPORT FROM
A DIVERSE COALITION OF
SPORTSMEN'S GROUPS CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS AND PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS AND AGRICULTURAL
REPRESENTATIVES- WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY IN SUPPORT IS
MARKEDLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION AND LOUIS
BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIGHTS COMMISSION.
RIGHT BOB PLEASE YOUR FIRST
WITNESS- PROCEED. CAN YOU HEAR
ME THAT IS MARKEDLY WITH
CALIFORNIA WATER PROBLEM. WE
CAN HEAR YOU. RIGHT ALL RIGHT-
IF YOU ARE AWARE AB SIX
FOURTEEN IS VERY SIMILAR TO AB
TWENTY ONE OH SIX BUT PASSED
THE COMMITTEE LAST YEAR.
CONNECTING BACK- BIRD HABITAT
INCENTIVE PROGRAM IS AN
EXISTING PROGRAM IN THE FIFTH
FISHING GAME CODE BUT IT LACKED
FUNDING. AB SIX WORKING WOULD
PROVIDE A FIVE DOLLAR SURCHARGE
ON BOTH STATE DOC IN UPLAND
GAME BIRD STAMP. WHICH OUR
MEMBERS MUST PURCHASE TO HUNT
GAME BIRDS. HELP START UP THE
PROGRAM. THERE'S A PRESSING
NEED FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS PROGRAM. BLACKTIP
SUFFICIENT VEGETATIVE COVER
SIGNIFICANT LIMITING FACTOR FOR
BREEDING WATERFOWL AND OTHER
CRAP WHEN NESTING BIRDS AS
IDENTIFIED IN BURKE HABITAT
PLAN FINE BUT IT IT CALIFORNIA.
STUDIES ALSO DEMONSTRATED THAT
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL NOTHING
COVERED THROUGH THE BREEDING
USING- CAN GREATLY BENEFIT
LOCAL WATERTOWN OTHER BIRDS.
FOR EXAMPLE THE RESULTS OF A
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN RIGHTS-
COVER CROP ROTATION PILOT
PROJECT FOUND THAT ANNUAL COVER
CROPS LOCATED YOU ADDICTED TO
RICE CULTIVATION. PRODUCED
ESPECIALLY HIGH AND NOT THINK
ABOUT I WAS ABOUT 39% OUR LOCAL
WATERFALL POPULATIONS HAVE
DECLINED- 36% STATEWIDE SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY TWO WHICH IS
VERY DISHEARTENING- IT SHOULD
ALSO BE NOTED THAT THERE WAS A
PILE OF OVER SIXTY THOUSAND
WATER TOPIC WOMEN'S REFUGES IN
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY- IT YOU TO
IT THAT THE OUTBREAK. MANY OF
THE BIRDS AFFECTED ONE
WATERFALL THAT READ IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BUT USE THE
KLAMATH REFUGES FOR MULTI
PURPOSES WHICH PUTS FURTHER
STRESS ON THEIR POPULATIONS-
THE NESTING BIRD HABITAT THAT A
PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO BE
FLEXIBLE FOR CALIFORNIA
GROWERS- IT WOULD PERMIT
FARMERS TO ROTATE THE FOLLOWING
FIELDS EACH YEAR. WOULD ALSO
INCENTIVIZE WHEAT FARMERS TO
DELAY HARVEST THEIR CROP. GET
NOTHING WATERTOWN OTHER BIRDS
ENOUGHTIMES SUCCESSFULLY
HATCHED BRAG. THE PROGRAM
BUILDS ON- THE HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL NON REGULATORY
APPROACH OF OTHER WATERFOWL
BIRD CONSERVATION INITIATIVES
THE PROBE PROVIDED FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES AND WORK
COOPERATIVELY WITH PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS- IN ADDITION TO
HELPING BIRDS AND OTHER
WILDLIFE THE PROGRAM WHICH
WESTER CARBON. IMPROVES SOIL
HELP THEM PROVIDE AIR QUALITY
THAT BENEFITS WHICH WAS
MENTIONED FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN CALLING
TODAY ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
RICE COMMISSION. HOW FOR ALL
THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED-
IN REGARDS TO THE NESTING BIRD
HABITAT PROGRAM AWARDS FOR THE
BILL WELL SOME SUPPORT- FOR THE
CHANGES THAT THE BILL PROVIDES
FOR THE CALIFORNIA WINNER RIGHT
HABITAT. INCENTIVE PROGRAM
WHICH INCENTIVIZES GROWERS IN
THE RIGHT INDUSTRY- TO FLOOD
THEIR FIELDS IN WINTERTIME SO
THAT- THIS IMPORTANT- THESE
THESE IMPORTANT WETLANDS COULD
BE MADE AVAILABLE FOR THE
PACIFIC FLYWAY. THE LANGUAGE
THAT WE WORKED INTO- THIS BILL
HAS BEEN AGREED UPON WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WILL REALLY
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY- AND GREATER
OPPORTUNITY TO INCREASE THE
ACREAGE- THAT PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PROGRAM NOW WITH IMPENDING
DROUGHT- WE BELIEVE THAT THESE
CHANGES ARE ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY. SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY HABITAT THAT WE'VE
DONE- PROUDLY FOR- WELL OVER
TWENTY YEARS SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M GOING TO
PAUSE BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO THE-
NEXT SET OF. ME TOO SO- TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SO MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. EDUARDO GARCIA PRESENT.
DOLLEY BENNETT. BIGELOW HERE
FRIEDMAN IS THE IN A GARCIA.
KALRA LEVINE. NEAR THIRTY NO
WHEN RUBIO SALAS SMITH WE HAVE
TO DO IT. WARD WE HAVE A QUORUM
THANK YOU SO WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND I JUST HAVE ONE ITEM LEFT-
OF HOUSEKEEPING YOU'RE NOT SAID
THE OPTION OF THE RULES FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
LEGISLATIVE SESSION CAN I GET A
MOTION TO THE UPPER. SECOND
TELLEM'S RUBIO FIRST BAPTIST
ALI- ROCK UP. EDUARDO GARCIA HI
EDUARDO GARCIA HI DOLLY DOLLY I
BENNETT BENNETT FIVE BIGELOW.
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA
GARCIA KALRA LEVINE LEVINE AYE
MERE SU CHI. WHEN I RUBIO RUBIO
AYE SALAS SMITH VIA PADURA WARD.
WARD I THANK YOU MA'AM
SECRETARY AT THIS TIME I'M
GOING TO ASK FOR ANY WITNESSES
THAT ARE IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO. SUPPORT THE MEASURE
THAT'S BEFORE US PLEASE STEP
FORWARD. STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. OR
MORE INFORMATION FROM THE
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE THANK YOU
FOR ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM-
WISHING TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THIS MATTER. OKAY ANYONE ON THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING- WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. WE'RE HEARING IN SEEN ON
ANYONE ON THE PHONE MISTER
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE.
CALLING IN IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. AND LANE JOHNSON ON
THE PHONE LINES PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. AND AT THIS TIME IT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE
IN THE QUEUE. ALL RIGHT LET'S
NOT GET THE FIRST ONE. I WILL
START WITH NUMBER ONE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK SMITH ON
BEHALF OF THE GRASSLAND WATER
DISTRICT AND THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA GUIDE SPORTSMEN'S
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PERSON.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS JAMIE
GO ON BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT PERSON. NEXT WILL BE
THE NUMBER ONE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE OF THE
MILANO- WITHOUT ABOUT
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THE NEXT
TO GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARE MEMBERS
GARY LINK WITH NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WILL BE
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER ONE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BILL
GAINES SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE TULARE BASIN'S WETLANDS
ASSOCIATION SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WILDLIFE FEDERATION THE BLACK
BRANT GROUPS SUED ME SOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION IN THE
CAL OR WETLANDS AND WATERFOWL
COUNSEL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SIX FORTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT WAS THE FIFTH AND FINAL
PERSONAL. ANYONE ELSE ON THE
LINE THIS MODERATOR. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE IN THE QUEUE OKAY. WHAT
PLEASE SEND. SURELY NUMBER ONE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KELLY HART ATTORNEYS BUT THE
CONVENTIONAL SPORTSMEN'S
FOUNDATION HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OKAY WE ARE
A BELIEVER NOW DONE WITH OUR-
SUPPORT- POSITIONS WILL GO ON
TO ASK ARE THERE TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. WE
DON'T HAVE IT TO WITNESSES ARE
THERE. ANY IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OKAY SEE
NO ONE. ANYONE ON THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE. OKAY SO WE MOVE ON
TO YOU MISTER MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYONE CALLING IN FOR
OPPOSITION OF THIS ITEM.
HANDLEY'S JUDGMENT YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION. THE TIME THERE
ARE NONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'LL BRING YOU BACK
TO. THE BODY HERE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS OR
IS THERE A MOTION TO MOVE. THIS
ITEM. THE WASHINGTON THREE ONE
SECOND WAS SALAS. NO QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO A CLOSE LET'S MAKE IT
EASY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU WITH THE
MOST IN A SECOND TO. A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS THAT SECTOR.
EDUARDO GARCIA HI EDUARDO
GARCIA HI DOLLY. DOLLY FIVE
BENNETT. BENNETT FIVE BIGELOW.
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN HI CRISTINA
GARCIA. KALRA LEVINE LEVINE AYE
MERE SU CHI WHEN NO RUBIO RUBIO
AYE SALAS SALAS I SMITH SMITH I
WOULD DO IT VIA VIDEO I WARD
WARD HI. THANK YOU- I LEAVE
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON I THINK WE'RE
ALMOST THERE BUT I BELIEVE
THAT- JUST TO BE SAFE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK. YOU WELL
BEFORE WE WANT TO THE SIDE OF
MY NECK TO ASK FOR A MOTION AND
SECOND FOR THE PROPOSED-
CONSECUTIVE. AND OKAY SALAS
SECOND BURMEISTER- ROCCA
EDUARDO GARCIA HI IN ORDER
GARCIA AYE DOLLY. DOLLY I
BENNETT. THEN IT I BIGELOW AYE
BIGELOW AYE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
HI CRISTINA GARCIA. KALRA
LEVINE LEVINE AYE MERE SU CHI.
WHEN YOU KNOW WHEN I RUBIO.
SALAS AYE SALAS AYE SMITH. WE
HAVE TO DO IT I CAN BE A
PRODUCER I WARD. WARD HI. THANK
YOU WILL GO HEAD LEAVE THAT
OPEN AS WELL FOR OTHER MEMBERS
TO ADD ON. WE ARE GOING BY
FINAL ORDER WE DO HAVE TO
COLLEAGUES AND ARE READY TO
PRESENT. THE FIRST ON WILL BE
AYE MR MATTIS. ZERO THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
BILL WOULD YOU LIKE TO START
WITH. PLEASE I HAVE TWO FOUR
YES WE HAVE ONE WHICHEVER ONE.
FIRST WHICH ARE NINE FIRST
IRELAND NINE TEN. LET'S START
WITH THE U. S. MORE SPICY ONE
HERE- MEMBERS I HAVE A AB FIVE
FIVE. FIFTY FOUR THIS IS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE OFFICE TO SET UP A ON
BOSMAN PROGRAM. THE GOLD ON
BUZZ BIN PROGRAM LIKE WE KNOW
WITH- DEALING WITH OUR ELDERLY
AND A LOT OF OTHER SYSTEMS THE
ON BUDGET MAN GIVES A- PERSON
FOR ANYBODY TO GO INVOICE A
CONCERN A COMPLAINT THAT'S
GOING ON- REGARDLESS IF IT'S A
ENVIRONMENTAL AGENCY THAT HAS
CONCERNED OVER POLICY OR THINGS
GOING ON. OR IF IT'S A HIKER OR
SOMEBODY WHO CONSIDERS
THEMSELVES A STEWARD. ON THE
IDEA HERE'S JUST WE KNOW OUR
FISHING GAME FOLKS ARE OUT
THERE THEY'RE TRYING TO DO
THEIR JOB THEY'RE TRYING TO
TAKE CARE OF OUR FORESTS ARE
ANIMALS OR WILDLIFE. IN THIS
JUST GIVES A VENUE SO THE
PUBLIC HAS AN OPTION TO GO
INVOICE A GRIEVANCE- IN
SOMEBODY THAT WILL ACTUALLY
LOOK INTO IT FOR THEM. AGAIN
VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DO WITH
OUR ON BODMIN FOR OUR- ELDERLY
HOMES. MEMBERS ASK YOU FOR AN
ADULT. WHO IS THE SECOND SORRY
JUST. WHEN RIGHT OKAY HELLO THE
THING. SEVEN OKAY DO YOU HAVE
ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES WITH. ALL
WITH THE TIMING OF TODAY MADAM
CHAIR AND I KNOW WE HAD
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES- IN THE
HERE AND I JUST LAUGHED I'M NOT
SURE IF THE PHONES ARE WORKING
OR NOT OR IF THEY'RE ON. AND I
KNOW EVERYBODY'S CONCERNED
ABOUT CATCHING FLIGHTS SO. OKAY
ONE ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM. THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. ON
THE LINE. MODERATOR TO HAVE
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE. HENLEY'S
GERMAN WHO WOULD IKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT HIS TIME AGAIN ONE
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. THIS TIME
THERE ARE NONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE. IS THERE
ANYONE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
I CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. THANK
THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON- MY
NAME IS KIM DELFINO AND I'M
REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY- THESE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE OPPOSING AB
FIVE FIVE FOUR- NOT BECAUSE
THEY OPPOSED THE CONCEPT OF
CREATING- AND- BENJAMIN OFFICE
OR CONDITIONS FOR RESOLVING
DISPUTES- BUT BECAUSE THE
CONCERNS WHAT SPECIFICALLY
OVER- JUST BEAT UP A PERMITS-
THE BILL CREATES AN OFFICE-
THAT IS REPORTING ONLY TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE FISHING GAME
COMMISSION- AND NOT WITH ANY
WITH ANY- MINUS FORTY WITHIN
THAT DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS
WILDLIFE- THE- THE BILL- IN
EXPLAINING AT THE BILL AT. ONE
OF THE ISSUES WITH TALKING
ABOUT RESOLVING ISSUES AROUND
PERMITTING AND- SO THERE IS A
QUESTION ABOUT IF THERE'S AN
OFFICE CREATED- THAT'S
REPORTABLE ONLY TO FISHING GAME
COMMISSION PRESIDENT WHO
ACTUALLY DOESN'T HAVE ANY-
DIRECT RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
ACTUAL PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS
ARE JURISDICTION IT'S A
QUESTION OF WHETHER THERE'S ANY
A PROCESS THAT WOULD WOULD BE
SET UP IN A WAY THAT COULD BE.
COULD RESOLVE THOSE TYPES OF
ISSUES THE OTHER PROBLEM IS
THAT- BY SETTING UP THE OFFICE
IT CREATES- EXAMS ALL
DISCUSSION- FROM THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT AND KEEP EVERYTHING
CONFIDENTIAL- WHICH MAKES SENSE
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE THAT ARE REPORTING-
EDUCATE VIOLATIONS WITHIN A
NURSING HOME AND YOU'RE TRYING
TO PROTECT THOSE PEOPLE FROM-
RETALIATION HERE- IF YOU'RE
SAYING- IT'S- THERE'S A REDUCED
YOU OVER A PERMIT. THERE'S THAT
MINISTRY TO RECORD THAT IS
CREATED AROUND THAT PERMIT BY
CREATING A SEPARATE SIDE THE
PROCESS IT EXEMPTS- THAT
ABILITY OF THE PUBLIC AND FOLKS
YOU KNOW LIKE WHAT KINDS OF
BACK AND FORTH ARE GOING ON
OVER THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THEIR NATURAL RESOURCES. LAWS-
SO. YOU KNOW FOR THE REASONS WE
DO THINK THE BILL AS CURRENTLY
DESIGNED. MAKES SENSE NOT WELL
ARE CERTAINLY ISSUES WITH THAT
OF IN TERMS OF- AROUND
PERMITTING WE ACTUALLY THINK A
BETTER. WAY OF RESOLVING SOME
THE PERMITTING ISSUES MIGHT BE
A WITH PROVIDING BETTER SUPPORT
FOR THE DEPARTMENT SO THAT THEY
CAN ACTUALLY ADMINISTER THEIR
LIVES AND I'LL LET I BELIEVE
THERE'S ANOTHER. WITNESS WHOSE-
IN OPPOSITION CAN SPEAK TO THAT
ISSUE MARKET THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT PERSON ON
THE TELEPHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRS CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
HEAR YOU. LOOK PERFECT- BRAND
OFTEN ACTING DIRECTOR OF THE
ARK OF CALIFORNIA- THE
RECYCLING OPPOSITION AB FOUGHT
BACK FOR TWO YEARS AGO THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTED TFW TA A
REVIEW OF ITS PROGRAM TO
DETERMINE. IF I HAD THE
NECESSARY CAPACITY CARRY ALL OF
ITS RESPONSIBILITIES. IN THIS
YEAR'S DFW REPORTED THAT IT WAS
CURRENTLY FUNDED TO CARRY OUT
LESS THAN 26% OF ITS REQUIRED
OBLIGATIONS FOR BERMAN WILL BE
A- WELL. SHARE TO COPY OVER.
BETTER MORE CONSTRUCTIVE
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING THE
PERMITTING ISSUES WITHIN AB
FIVE FIVE FOUR PM W. AND BE
ABLE TO- HAVE SUFFICIENT
FUNDING AND STAFFING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO. DO THE WORK.
SECRET UNACCOUNTABLE
OMBUDSMAN'S OFFICE. I TO MARKET
YOU. COSTS FOR- AND MUST
PROTECTION WITHOUT THE
RESOURCES THAT THE A COUPLE
YEARS HISTORY UP SO WHAT ARE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ANOTHER
THANK YOU. Q. ANY OTHER-
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ON THE TELEPHONE
LINE. AND LATER GERMAN ON THE
PHONE LINE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND AT THIS
TIME LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE- THREE
IN THE QUEUE. PLEASE PROCEED.
WE'LL START WITH NUMBER ONE
THIRTY NINE- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PATRON AFTER CAROLINE BURKE
THIS IS JENNIFER APPEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE MOUNTAIN LION
FOUNDATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THE NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO ONE OF THEM WE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT WITH AUTO ONE CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER ONE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM NOT IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO-
ADDRESSED THE COMMITTEE IF IT'S
ON THE SUBJECT MATTER GIVEN
THAT YOU'RE ON THE LINE OR
SHOULD WE- PUT YOU ON HOLD FOR
THE OF THE ITEM THAT YOU'RE
WISHING TO SPEAK ON. I ON. WAY
BACK IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU. IT
IS. NICE CHAIR GIVE PEOPLE
CHOICES HERE. ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO- CALLING. IN
OPPOSITION CAMPS ARE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
WELL I WILL- THE BRING BACK TO
THE BODY HERE TO. SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS- FOR THE- THE MATTER
BEFORE US. WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND THERE'S A SECOND TO START
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
I ASK- DO WE CALL MEASURE BOTH
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IN CLOSING- I UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS FROM THE OPPOSITION AS
YOU ALL KNOW ME- LOT OF US WORK
TOGETHER IN THE PAST ON MUCH
MORE SERIOUS ISSUES I'M ALWAYS
WILLING TO TAKE AMENDMENTS TO
SIT DOWN WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
WORK OUT ANY CONCERNS THEY HAVE
OVER PERMITTING OVER
TRANSPARENCY- TO ENSURE THAT
THIS IS A FAIR. TYPE OF
POSITION WITH THE ON BODMIN- I
DO UNDERSTAND. THE PROGRAM THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE A FOURTEEN
BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS DURING
THE COVERED RECESSION- IN THE
FACT JUST LOOKING AT HOW MUCH
MONEY WE BLEW AN EASY D. WITH
THE TEN POINT FOUR BILLION LOSS
THERE. I'M SURE ON. IT'S A
REASONABLE AMOUNT TO BE ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO ENSURE. THAT
PEOPLE AGAIN ON EITHER SIDE CAN
HAVE A PLACE TO GO. WITH
GRIEVANCES TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
VOICES ARE BEING HEARD WHEN IT
COMES THE DEPARTMENT. ASK YOU
AGAIN MEMBERS WORK WITH ME I'M
ALWAYS WILLING TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU SIR WE'LL CALL
QUESTIONS. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO
GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA HI DOLLY
DOLLY I BENNETT. SENATE NO
BIGELOW BIGELOW HI FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NOT VOTING CRISTINA
GARCIA KALRA. LEVINE LEVINE NO
MURATSUCHI NO N. NO AND I RUBIO
RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I SMITH.
SMITH I HAVE TO DO IT VIA VIDEO
I WARD WARD NOW. OKAY THE LABEL
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR OTHERS
THAT ON YOUR NEXT ITEM NUMBER
NINE I THINK YOU ISTER CHAIR
OUR NEXT ITEM. IS SHOULD HAVE A
LOT MORE SUPPORT ON IT. IT IS
AB FIVE FIFTY FORTY TWO STE
THIS IS THE STATE PARK FORT
INTEREST FEE WAIVERS FOR OUR
FOURTH GRADE CHILDREN. IT WILL
NOT TAKE THAT AS MY CLOSE THIS
IS JUST FURTHERS CONTINUES THE
PROGRAM BROUGHT TO US BY THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION IT IS
CHANGED- FROM EVERY. IN A PARK
TO EVERY KID OUTDOORS UNDER THE
NEW CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
MEMBERS I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS MEASURE IN OUR
KIDS. OFF THE COMPUTERS AND
SCREENS AND OUT INTO NATURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU I WILL ASK-
DO TWO WITNESSES SUPPORT YES I
BELIEVE ALL RIGHT WHAT IF YOU
ONLINE. OKAY SO YOUR FIRST TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH ARM
WILL YOU PLEASE- PROCEED. I'M
NOT SURE THE ORDER CAN YOU HEAR
ME THIS IS JENNIFER APPEARING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUSEUMS. GREAT
THANK YOU AND TELL ME THE
IMPROVEMENTS FROM SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE FORTY TWO. CALIFORNIA THE
END INCLUDING MANY STATE PARKS
SUPPORT THE STATE EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM AND SERVE K. TWELVE
SCHOOL CHILDREN IN COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS. CALIFORNIA
MUSEUM EXHIBITIONS AND PROGRAMS
PROVIDE ACCESS TO EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES EXCITING AND
HANDS ON LEARNING EXPERIENCES
INFORMATION AND THE CULTURAL
AND NATURAL HERITAGE THAT
DEFINES US AS A STATE. WE ARE
DRIVE OKAY ON EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
TWO AND APPLY THE SEPARATE TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO NATURAL
CULTURAL AND HISTORICAL
EXPERIENCES FOR CALIFORNIA'S
FOURTH GRADERS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. HELLO MAY I
PROCEED YES PLEASE. THANK YOU
HELLO I'M DOCTOR CAMERA
REVELING IN PRINCETON AND I
TELL UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND I'M SPEAKING YESTERDAY TO
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS IN
SUPPORT AND EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
TWO I REPRESENT OVER TWENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND STUDENTS IN MY
SCHOOL DISTRICT THE MAJORITY OF
WHOM ARE CLASSIFIED AS
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED AND
THIS IS THE CASE FOR MOST
STUDENTS IN TULARE COUNTY AS
WELL AS THE ENTIRE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. EDUCATORS WE WORK
TOWARDS PROVIDING ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND IN DOING
SO IT'S OUR JOB TO ELIMINATE
BARRIERS TO ACT WITHIN
OPPORTUNITIES EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
CHIU DOES JUST THAT BY
SUPPORTING OUR AND FAMILIES BY
ELIMINATING THE BARRIER OF
COSTS FOR PARK ENTRANCE FEES
AND THAT IS A BARRIER FOR MANY
OF OUR FAMILY. RESEARCH
CONSISTENTLY REINFORCES THE
VALUE IN MAKING CLASSROOM
LEARNING EXPERIENCES CONNECT
YOUR REAL LIFE EXPERIENCES
ADDITIONALLY RESEARCH HAS
DEMONSTRATED THAT OUTDOOR
LEARNING EXPERIENCES CORRELATE
WITH ENHANCED SCIENCE
ACHIEVEMENT BY VISITING OUR
STATE PARKS INCLUDING CREATURE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THE DIVERSITY
THAT EXISTS WITHIN OUR STATE.
GIVING OUR STATE PARK ALLOWS
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE HISTORY
OF OUR GREAT STATE AND PROVIDES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CAREERS IN
RECREATION WITHIN OUR PARK
SYSTEM. I BUILT ON EIGHTY FIVE
FORTY SHE WAS VITAL TO OUR
STUDENTS LEARNING AND THEIR
FUTURE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY.
MUCH THANK YOU PAMELA. IT IN
THE VIDEO COMP ROOM- WILL ONE
TO TESTIFY I ON AS A TOO. IN
THE ROOM SORRY. YEAH YEAH A LOT.
BOB LANDED SUPPORT THANKS FOR
ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM. WE
SHOULD TO SUPPORT THE MEASURE.
CASINO ONE WILL GO TO THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM ANYONE.
WAITING TO TESTIFIED FOR THE
BUILDER. CASEIN NO ONE COME
FORWARD- PHONE WILL GO TO THE-
FONG WITNESSES. MISTER
MODERATOR. HANLEY'S JOHN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO ONE ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT.
AT THIS TIME THAT WE HAVE ABOUT
THREE IN THE QUEUE. PLEASE
PROCEED. AND WE'LL START WITH
NUMBER ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON CHENEY
COUNTY HAPPENS CALIFORNIA
RELEASE AS WELL AS LOOKING OUT
FOR THE PART THANK YOU Q. NEXT
WILL BE NUMBER ONE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO WE
DIDN'T GET A LETTER IN THE FALL
BUT WE DON'T KNOW- OUT OF ON
CALIFORNIA. IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT TO BE NUMBER ONE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE MARKEDLY WITH
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. ANY
OTHER. FOLKS ON THE PHONE- FOR
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. WE DO
HAVE A ONE MORE- WILL GO TO
NUMBER ONE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS NATALIE
VERGARA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY
START ANY OTHER WITNESSES ON
THE PHONE LINE WILL MOVE ON TO
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WANT TO
OPPOSE THE BILL. YOU WERE IN
THE ROOM. ALL RIGHT ANYONE ON
THE VIDEO CONFERENCE. WE WANT
TO YOU MISTER MODERATOR ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
CALLING IN. IF YOU ARE NOW IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE
AN OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE MR THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND I
BELIEVE- SO THIRD ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS TO THE
AUTHOR WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
I'LL TAKE THAT AS MY CLOSEST IN
STRUCTURE. THANK YOU PLEASE
CALL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA.
HOLDEN PERCENT WAS OWNER I'M
GONNA OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS
A COUPLE. FROM THE SEPTEMBER.
AND I'LL ONLY TAKE JOINT
AUTHORS AS WELL. OKAY WE'LL
OPEN IT UP FOR THAT BUT ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
BEFORE WE TAKE THE ROLE. PLEASE
THANK YOU TERRY I REALLY WANT
EXPRESS APPRECIATION FOR THIS I
THINK IT'S REALLY EXCITING I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
THIS INITIATIVE- THE- YOU KNOW
EVERY KID IN A PARK PASS- IT'S
JUST BEEN A WHILE SUCCESS AND I
THINK. REALLY REALLY GOOD FOR.
INSTILLING IN THEM AT THAT AGE
AND APPRECIATION FOR NATIONAL
PARKS- AND I HOPE FOR THE
SUCCESS AND I WAS GOING TO SOME
CONVERSATIONS AROUND BUDGET AND
JUST IN GENERAL I WANT TO BE
VERY SUPPORT OF OUR PARKS
BUDGETS. ON THE IDEA THAT-
ESPECIALLY AS EXPENSIVE AS SOME
OF THESE ENTRY FEES ARE
ALREADY. YOU KNOW HOW THAT
PROHIBITS ESPECIALLY MODERATE
LOW INCOME. CALIFORNIANS FOR ME
ABLE TO EVEN ACCESS THESE
PARKS- I SEE MANY OF THEM AS
NOT EVEN TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
IT IN THE FIRST PLACE SO. IF
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO PAY THE FEE
IN THE FIRST PLACE HOW IS THERE
GOING TO BE UP AT THAT DEFICIT
TO THE BUDGET WITH ITS KIND OF
PERSPECTIVE I HAVE.
CONVERSATION PROBABLY FOR A
PHYSICAL COMMITTEE. ON ONE
HELPFUL SO THAT ONE WOULD
SUGGEST AND I'D LOVE TO SEE
THIS GO FORWARD- IT IS SIDE.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO THINK ABOUT.
HAVING APPLICABLE FOURTH AND
FIFTH GRADERS OR EVEN JUST
FIFTH GRADERS IN THE REASON I
SAY THAT IS TO HAVE. THIS THE
FOUNDATION OF THIS IS TO REALLY
USE THAT AGE TO GET PEOPLE
INSPIRED. IF WE ALREADY HAVE
THIS PROGRAM IT'S REALLY SORT
OF TARGETING PEOPLE TO HEAD TO
THE NATIONAL PARKS. AND
FAMILIES ONLY HAVE SO MANY
VACATION DAYS WE ONLY HAVE SO
MUCH TIME TO REALLY GET OUT
THERE. WITH PIGGY BACK ON THAT
AND REALLY EXTEND THAT TOWARDS
THE FIFTH GRADE SO IT'S JUST A
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME. TO REALLY
I THINK- IMPLICATE OF THE
INTEREST IN OUR- PUBLIC PARKS.
MR WARD I'D I'D LOVE TO WORK ON
THAT WITH YOU NEXT YEAR.
SOMETIMES. IN ABSOLUTE SILENCE.
X. NOT A NOT A NOT SUGGEST.
THAT IT OR IF AS WE GET.
THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS WITH
WITH ALL OF SUPPORT- MAKE THE
ECOMMERCE WE HAVE. WITH THE
CHAIR THERE I DO THAT THE RAIN
I'M REALLY HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS TODAY THANK YOU FOR.
ANYWHERE ELSE ONE AS QUESTION
OR CHINA. OKAY WE GOT MORE SICK
WILL. THE MOTION IS PASS TO.
EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I
DALI DALI I BENNETT BENNETT I
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
KALRA LEVINE LEVINE I'M
MURATSUCHI. WHEN NEWMAN AYE
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS AYE
AYES SMITH. SMITH I HAVE TO DO
IT VIA VIDEO I'D WARD WARD I.
THANK YOU WILL LEAVE THE ROLE-
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD
ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE LOOKS
A PRESENTER WILL BE MR
GALLAGHER. HE HAS THIRTY BILLS
ON THE AGENDA. IT'S GOT TO BE
READY.
YES CHAIRMAN IT'S AN
ABSOLUTE PLEASURE TO BE BACK IN
THE COMMITTEE- THIS AFTERNOON.
AND I DO HAVE A FEW MEASURES
BEFORE YOU- BUT I'LL START WITH
AB SIX FORTY FIVE THAT'S OKAY.
SOME SECURING MEMBERS AB SIX
FORTY FIVE IS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE- THIS PROTECTING OUR
WILDLIFE IN THE STATE-
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF- SOME
THINGS THAT HAVE HAPPENED- WE
ARE NOT SEEING THE KIND OF
PENALTIES- AND PUNISHMENT FOR
POACHING OF OUR WILDLIFE- AND
THIS BILL IS AN ATTEMPT TO.
START TO REMEDY THAT THAT
PROBLEM ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- REPEAT OFFENSES
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PRETTY
EGREGIOUS EXAMPLES OF.
THIRTEEN- AND TAKING OUT
WILDLIFE AND OUR STATE
ILLEGALLY- SO SPECIFICALLY AB
SIX FORTY FIVE WOULD RE
ESTABLISH A MAXIMUM THREE YEAR
PROBATION SENTENCE. FOR
SPECIFIED SERIOUS WILDLIFE
POACHING VIOLATIONS- I DO HAVE
SOME WITNESSES HERE TO HELP
TESTIFIED AS TO THE NEED FOR
THIS BILL- AND THEY INCLUDE-
ROY GRIFFITHS WITH A RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION. AND A
FORMER DISTRICT ATTORNEY LARRY
ALLEN HAS DONE MANY OF THESE
CASES IN HIS HIS CAREER. HI
THANK YOU OF CALL OF YOUR FIRST
WITNESS ARE THE ARE HERE
PRESENT OR THEY ON. THE LINE.
TELEPHONE TELEPHONE RIGHT THIS
WILL SAVE. THEY ARE HERE IN
PERSON OKAY MISTER CHAIRMAN ALL
RIGHT. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS FLORIN SALAM I WAS
ELECTED DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
YOU'RE A COUNTY FOR SIXTEEN
YEARS STILL SERVES A DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. PRIOR TO
THAT I WAS A CIRCUIT VARNELL
PROSECUTOR PRIOR TO THAT I WAS
A- OUT OF SHASTA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. AS
A CERTAIN OF OUR MENTAL
PROSECUTOR I SAW- I HANDLE THE
FOURTEEN NORTHERNMOST
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES AND I SAW
MANY A VERY EGREGIOUS
SUFFICIENT WILDLIFE VIOLATIONS
WAS KIND OF WHAT I DID. AND
THIS BILL IS MEANT TO ADDRESS
THE COMMERCIAL POACHER AND-
DOES THIS IS THE WORST OF THE
WORST THIS ISN'T THIS BILL IS
NOT DESIGNED FOR SOMEBODY WHO
HAS TOO MANY FISH IN A BASKET.
THIS IS FOR THE COMMERCIAL
POACHERS THOSE WHO TAKE THE
WILDLIFE AND MAKE MONEY OFF OF
IT AND TAKE IT OVER OVER OVER
AGAIN AND- WE A FEW YEARS AGO
WE CAME OF THE LEGISLATURE ASK
FOR FILLING PROVISIONS. ON
COMMERCIAL POACHING AND
PARTICULARLY ABALONE POACHING
BECAUSE OUR RESOURCES
PARTICULAR APOLLONIA SO FRAGILE
THAT IT WAS NOT STOP THERE
WON'T BE ANY OUT BONUS SO
SIMPLE. THE LEGISLATURE
RESPONDED WITHOUT THE ONLY
PROVISIONS BUT THEY DID GIVE US
HIGH POINTS SO WE HAVE REALLY
HIGH POINT ASSOCIATED WITH
THESE CRIMES AND THEY NEED TIME
TO PAY THEM OFF AND THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF AN EXTENDED
PROBATIONARY PERIOD. TO GET
ALLOW THEM TO PAY OFF OF FOR
INSTANCE POACHING OF A
COMMERCIAL POACHING OF ABALONE
IS A FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLAR
MINIMUM POINT WHICH WITH FAMILY
ASSESSMENTS TRANSLATION. TO
FORTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THEY NEED TIME TO PAY THE FINE
OFF. AND THAT'S WHY WE NEEDED
EXTENT ALL ALSO WE WANT TO
IMPOSE BE ABLE TO IMPOSE. DO
NOT HUNT DO NOT FISH THOSE KIND
OF PENALTIES ASSOCIATED WITH
HIS AGREE JUST TYPE VIOLATIONS.
SO WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU.
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AND PASS
IT PLEASE THANK YOU THANK YOU
YOUR NEXT WITNESS. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS RUGGER FOR SPEAKING ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION BUT MORE SO
TODAY SPEAKING AS RETARGETING
MORTON THIRTY TWO YEARS. I'M
HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR. THE
VICTIMS OF THESE CRIMES I CAN'T
TESTIFY FOR OURSELVES. NOT I'VE
BEEN IN THIS BUILDING MANY
TIMES TO WATCH A LOT OF
TESTIMONY OF VICTIMS OF CRIMES
TESTIFYING IT'S ALWAYS VERY
MOVING. FOR THE WILDLIFE AND
DID RESOURCE THAT WE'RE HERE TO
PROTECT DAY CAN'T TESTIFY FOR
THEMSELVES. I'M ALSO HERE TO
REPRESENT GAME WARDENS IT
BECAUSE OUR STATE EMPLOYEES
THEY CAN'T STAND FROM THIS MIKE
EITHER AND- SINCE I RETIRED
I'VE A FREE SOUL NOW AND I CAN
SAY WHAT I BELIEVE. THIS BILL
THAT ASTRONOMER GALLAGHER IS
DOING IS CRITICAL I ANNOT TELL
YOU HOW HARD IT IS TO MAKE SOME
OF THESE CASES. MY COLLEAGUES
SPEAK ALREADY ON BEHALF OF
PROSECUTORS IN WHAT IT MEANS
FOR THEM TO HAVE THESE THESE
TOOLS IN THEIR TOOL BELT. BUT
FOR GAME MORE TO SPEND
COUNTLESS HOURS SOMETIMES YEARS
IN THE FIELD TO MAKE THESE
CASES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
MOST GRIEVOUS VIOLATORS WHO PUT
A PRICE TAG ON OUR WILDLIFE AND
OUR RESOURCES HEAD. TO MAKE
MONEY OFF OF IT. AND NOT JUST
AGAIN THAT PERSON JUST SHOOTS A
FEW HOURS BEFORE SHE TIME A FEW
MINUTES AFTER SHE TIME. THESE
FOLKS SET OUT EVERY DAY TO RIP
OFF OUR RESOURCES EVERYBODY IN
THIS ROOM EVERYBODY THE STATE.
IS A VICTIM OF THESE CRIMES.
AND IT MEANS SO MUCH OF THE
GAME WORKS A BILL TO PUT THESE
PEOPLE OUT OF THE FIELD IT'S
CRITICAL FOR WILDLIFE TO GET
HIM OUT OF FUEL. AND THESE
POACHERS DON'T LIMIT THEIR
ACTIVITIES TO JUST TO
CALIFORNIA. THESE FOLKS POACH
ALL OVER THE WESTERN UNITED
STATES IF NOT NORTH AMERICA.
THAT'S WHY THE PROBATION TERMS
THAT WERE SEEKING TO RETAIN
THIS BILL THE THREE YEARS IS
CRITICAL TO GET THESE FOLKS
WHAT'S CALLED A WHILE LEADERS
VIOLATOR OF. INTERNATIONAL
WHILE LEADERS OF VIOLATORS
COMPACT IT TAKES ALMOST A YEAR
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND WITH
THE CURRENT TERMS OF JUST A
YEAR PROBATION. WE DON'T HAVE A
CHANCE TO GET MEN CONTACT NOW
WE PUT A LOT OF BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT THROUGHOUT THE
NATION. SO I CAN'T TELL YOU
ENOUGH HOW MUCH I BELIEVE- MY
PASSION FOR THIS MEASURE SHINES
THROUGH. IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
JUST WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR MORE
JUST ASKING TO PROTECT WAS
ALREADY THERE TO GET. US TO LET
THE GAME MORE TO CAL. ANYA TO
REST LIVES EVERY DAY. TO
PROTECT YOUR- TO DO THEIR JOB.
AND PUT FOLKS OUT OF BUSINESS
SO PLEASE WITH ALL THE- I ASK
FOR YOUR I. THANK YOU SIR.
ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM WISHING
TO SPEAK SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
A GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS GERRY
CARNOT HOME SOME OF YOU MIGHT
RECOGNIZE ME I USED TO BE THE-
WAS A THE PREVIOUS- FISHING
GAME WARDENS ASSOCIATION
PRESIDENT- NOW RETIRED GAME
WARDEN AFTER THIRTY YEARS. I
FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR ANYONE ELSE.
IN SUPPORT SEE NO ONE VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM ANYONE SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT. SEE NO ONE- PHONE
LINE SIR MODERATOR. BECAUSE
SUPPORT YEAH LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE ABOUT- SEVEN IN THE QUEUE
CURRENTLY THANK YOU. WE'LL
START WITH NUMBER ONE THIRTY
NINE- PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN THE CHURCH CARE
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
FEARING I WANTED TO EXPRESS THE
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX FORTY
FIVE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME
WARDENS SUPERVISORS AND
MANAGERS ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ACTUALLY NUMBER ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CAPITALIZE
REPRESENTING THE OUTDOOR SPORTS
AND COALITION OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA SPORTS BOBBY AND THE
PARTICLE OF INTERNATIONAL
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
MEASURE FOR WILDLIFE I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
UP FOR WORK ON THE COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
TO BE NUMBER ONE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN GARCIA AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CAN DELFINO
REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ITSELF. SPEAKER NEXT WE'LL GO
TO NUMBER ONE FORTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS BILL GAINES SPEAKING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING FOR
CONSERVATION THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER THE WILD SHEEP
FOUNDATION THE CALIFORNIA DEER
ASSOCIATION ROCKY MOUNTAIN ELK
FOUNDATION AND SEVERAL OTHER
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. OF AB SIX FORTY FIVE.
SIR. NEXT TO BE NUMBER ONE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MARK KELLY WITH CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WEEK. NEXT WE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE MAKE
SURE NOT ON MUTE. WILL MOVE ON
TO NUMBER ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ECONOMY DONALD WITH
I'M I'M CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. I WILL GO TO
NUMBER ONE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOUR HUSBAND BUT THE
COMPRESSIONAL SPORTSMEN
FOUNDATION HERE TODAY AND
SUPPORT. AND AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU SIR ANY WITNESSES OUT
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THE MEASURE. ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE.
VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM. LOCAL
PHONE LINES WHICH MODERATOR. IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
THIS TIME THERE ARE NONE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MR WILL
BRING YOU BACK TO THE BODY HERE
TO QUESTIONS. EXCELLENT. THANKS
VERY MUCH THANKS MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANKS-
CINEMATOGRAPHER FOR INTRODUCING
THIS I'M I'M KIND OF. HAVING A
BIT OF A DISCONNECT RELATED TO
THE SHORT SHORTENING OF
PROBATIONARY PERIODS IN GENERAL
IN CALIFORNIA AND THE BE-
ANALYSIS DOES TALK ABOUT THE
RECENT PASSAGE OF AB NINETEEN
FIFTY. I DON'T RECALL HOW YOU
VOTED BY IMAGINING VOTED
AGAINST IT- YOU CORRECT IF I'M
WRONG I BET PERHAPS SOME OF THE
DA'S OF THE WARDENS WOULD HAVE
BEEN AGAINST IT AS WELL- SO I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S FAIR. TO ASK
THEM ABOUT ABOUT THAT
DISCONNECT BUT I WOULD BE GLAD
TO HEAR. YOUR WITNESSES WAY N.
ON. BEAT BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
REALLY SEEN THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE ONE YEAR PROBATIONARY
PERIOD WHEN HAVE THEY GIVEN.
PROBATIONARY PERIODS OF
DIFFERENT DURATION. AND THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF ONE OF THOSE
PERIODS WHEN HAVE THEY SAID
WELL THIS IS A ONE YEAR
PROBATIONARY PERIOD I SEE IN IT
AN EXAMPLE IN THE ANALYSIS OF
THE THREE YEAR AND A BIG FINE
THAT HAPPENED- IN ELDORADO-
COUNTY. IF SO COULD YOU CALL
WALK ME THROUGH HOW THEY PURSUE
THE DIFFERENT LENGTHS OF
PROBATIONARY PERIOD AND WHAT
THE RECIDIVISM IS FOR THAT FOR
US TO CONSIDER WALKING BACK A
VERY SIGNIFICANT REFORM JUST
PASSED. A FEW MONTHS AGO. YOU
KNOW ALL THAT- PERHAPS- LARRY
WOULD BE ABLE TO SPEAK TO THAT
AS A FORMER DA- AS YOU KNOW
NINETEEN FIFTY WAS A VERY BROAD
ACROSS THE BOARD I DON'T EVEN
THINK IT WAS REALLY THE INTENT
TO DO THIS FOR THESE TYPES OF
CRIMES AND SO WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO SAY HEY FOR THESE CRIMES
LET'S TAKE THAT BACK TO THE
THREE YEAR PROBATION. AND
REALLY WHAT PROBATION DOES IT
TAKES WHETHER HUNTING THEY WILL
NOW NO LONGER BE ABLE TO HUNT
FOR THOSE THREE YEARS NO MATTER
HIS LIVELIHOOD PERHAPS WE GOT
YOU KNOW PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING
THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
MAYBE ONLY. YOU KNOW. LOSING
LOSING THEIR LICENSE FOR ONE
YEAR MINIMAL PENALTIES. THAT
DOESN'T REALLY DETER PEOPLE
FROM DOING THIS AGAIN. APPS CAN
AND I THINK FOR THE FORMER DA
I'D LOVE TO HEAR THAT THAT
COMMENTARY BUT ALSO IF THEY'RE
WILLING TO POACH WELL WHY NOT
DO IT WITHOUT THE LICENSE
ANYHOW SO TO JUST DESCRIBE YOU
KNOW WHAT IS WHAT IS THAT
CRIMINAL ELEMENT THINKING
ABOUT. DOING THIS. WELL MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU. WELL THE
OF. AS I UNDERSTAND IT THE
LEGISLATION THAT SHORT THE
PROBATIONARY PERIOD DID CARVE
OUT EXCEPTIONS. ONE OF THOSE
EXCEPTIONS WAS FOR DO YOU WHY.
DO YOU WHY DID DRIVING UNDER
THE INFLUENCE OBVIOUSLY HAS A
LONGER PROBATIONARY PERIOD
BECAUSE- AGAIN IT'S A HIGH FIND
A NEEDS TO BE PAID OFF. BUT IT
ALSO GIVES THE ABILITY TO. FILE
A PROBATION YOUR ANSWERS SOME
SORT OF VIOLATION THE FUTURE
DRIVING WITHOUT A LICENSE EVEN.
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT THAT
WOULD VIOLATE THE TERMS OF A
PROBATION. MISDEMEANOR
PROBATION IS REALLY NOT A BIG
DEAL. IT'S A PROBATION TO THE
COURT ONLY THEY'RE NOT RESPOND
OR NOT- GOING BACK TO PROBATION
OFFICER. IT'S ONLY TO A COURT.
AND IT IS LIKE OF SOMETHING
COMES UP AND- THEY WANT TO COME
BACK AND GET IT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE. IS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT I WOULD MUCH RATHER
HAVE FELONY PROVISIONS. FOR
COMMERCIAL POACHING- BUT AS
LONG AS WE'RE GOING TO HAVE.
THE YOU KNOW THE HIGH FINES
AND- AND BROOKE PROHIBITIONS WE
NEED SOME WAY TO ENFORCE IT.
AND PROBATION IS THE EASIEST
WAY TO ENFORCE IT. BECAUSE OF
PROBATION VIOLATION IS A
HEARING BEFORE A JUDGE WITH A
LOWER STANDARD OF PROOF IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE A JURY TRIAL.
AND BRING ALL THE PEOPLE AND TO
PROVE UP OF. A PROBATION
VIOLATION SO IT'S A LOT EASIER
PROVEA PROBATION VIOLATION OR
DISPROVE UP. US A SEPARATE
OFFENSE. AND YOU KNOW AGAIN
THEY NEED THE TIME TO PAY OFF
THE FINE SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
A HIGH FINES WE NEED TO HAVE
TIME TO PAY MORE. SO IT TOOK
YOU CAN. APPROACH THE POINT
ABOUT WHEN YOU HAVE SOUGHT ONE
YEAR OR TWO YEAR OR THREE YEARS
AND HOW THAT DOES IN FACT.
AFFECT BEHAVIOR OF THE POACHER.
AND WHETHER DURATION THAT
YOU'VE AND I'M JUST TRUSTING
YOU TO GIVE ME GOOD GOOD DATA
GOOD STORY ABOUT THIS BUT DOES
NOT REALLY IMPACT A CHANGE IN
BEHAVIOR. OR IS THAT JUST A
PUNITIVE MEASURE- YOU KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE AN OF GAME AWARDS IN
THE STATE IS IT IS WE HAVE VERY
FEW GAME AWARDS BUT WHEN. YOU
HAVE SOMEBODY CONVICTED OF AN
OFFENSE LIKE THIS THEY WATCH
THEM. THEY PAY ATTENTION TO
WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND THEY DO
COME BACK AND THAT DOES HAVE AN
IMPACT ON WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
FUTURE MMHM VERY MUCH SO. AND
AS A ROY POINTED OUT THEY GET
IN THE CONTACT TO GO TO ANOTHER
STATE TO TRY TO HALT EVEN. TO
GET PICKED UP A VIDEO YES THEY
DO CONTACT IS IT IS A NET
NATIONWIDE- SYSTEM THAT TARGETS
POACHERS. AND THEY CAN PICK WE
CAN PICK THEM UP HERE AND WE
HAVE. WE HAVE A PROSECUTOR FROM
OUT OF STATE. MANY TIMES YEAH
AND I THINK THIS FOR ME TO BE
HELPFUL IN LEARNING ABOUT THIS
THIS PROBATION IS A VERY
DIFFERENT PUNITIVE MEASURE.
THAN WHAT WE ARE TYPICALLY
THINKING ABOUT WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT PROBATION FOR OTHER-
MISDEMEANORS THAT THAT PEOPLE
ARE CONVICTED OF. I THINK
THAT'S TRUE YEAH. I THINK I
WOULD AGREE WITH THAT. AND ONLY
BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE AT THE
LEVEL OF A COMMODE COMMERCIAL
POACHER. THEN EVERYBODY'S
WATCHING. ALL THE AT THE GAME
AWARDS ALL KNOW WHO THIS PERSON
CHEMOURS ARE VERY CLOSE KNIT
GROUP OF LAW ENFORCEMENT WITHIN
THE STATE. AND THEY KNOW WHO
THESE FOLKS ARE. IN THE FALL IN
FACT WHEN I WAS A CIRCUIT
PROSECUTOR. I GET A BEAR
POACHING. OF CASE IN SISKIYOU
COUNTY AND I GO DOWN TO SEE
YOUR CANDIDATE THE- BEAR
HUNTERS THERE ALREADY KNEW WHO
I WAS. ARE YOU MY NAME THEY
KNEW WHAT I DID AND IF YOU
COULD JUST ADDRESS HOW YOU
WOULD DETERMINE THE DURATION OF
PROBATION. OF GENERAL IS
NEGOTIATED. IT'S NO GOOD SHOULD
GO SHE'D WITH THE DEFENDERS
ATTORNEY. I HAD ONE CASE WHERE
A GUY WAS. LURING BEARS OUT OF
LASSEN PARK. BUT A GUIDE. AND
HE WOULD TAKE HIS HIS HIS
CLIENT UP THERE. AND HE HAD A
BIG A BIG PILOTS LESSONS THE
ONLY BELIEVE HAVE A GUN LAST
PARK WILL HUNT. SO HE WAS
WILLING THE BEARS OUTSIDE
LASSEN PARK. AND HIS CLIENTS
WOULD PAY MONEY TO GO UP AND
BEAR THEY ALWAYS GOT A FAIR
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO BE
AROUND THE STATE. AND IF YOU
HAVE WITH A TEN THOUSAND DOLLAR
FINE. FIVE YEARS NO HUNTING.
AND BASICALLY SHOWS GUIDING
BUSINESS DOWN- BUT AGAIN THAT
WAS A- AND THE WAY HE GOT
VIOLATED BECAUSE YOU. ONE
HUNDRED IN A DIFFERENT STATE
AND CAUGHT UP WITH. SO IT DOES
WORK I THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS IF I COULD
JUST HAVE ONE MINUTE TO ADDRESS
SYSTEMS QUESTION ABOUT THE
MINDSET OF THE POACHER YES
PLEASE GO ONE RESPECT YOU ASK
WHY NOT WHAT IS THE POSTER JUST
GO HUNT WITHOUT A LICENSE. AND
THEY DO BUT THE BEAUTY OF THAT
THE REASON THE GAME WARDENS
NEED THIS PROBATION IS IT TAKES
SO MUCH TO LINE UP ALL THOSE
PLANETS TO CATCH VIOLATORS.
VIOLATING WHEREAS WITH THE
PROBATION TERMS OF NO HONEY YOU
KNOW IF THEY CHOOSE TO HOME
WITHOUT A LICENSE THEN THE GAME
MORE HAS THAT INDIVIDUAL HIM OR
HER DURING THE FIELD FOR JUST
BEING THERE WITH IMPLEMENTS A
TAKE. AND THEN THE ALREADY
GAUTAM AS OPPOSED TO IF THEY
COULD LEGALLY HAVE THAT LICENSE
IN HERE THEN CAME WORDS BACK TO
SQUARE ONE HAVE TO LINE ALL
THOSE PLANETS UP AGAIN TO CATCH.
THAT INDIVIDUAL DOES THAT HELP
SIR. YEAH I KNOW IT IT DOES
HELP I HAVE NO PLACE IN MY
HEART FOR POACHERS A HORSE IS
LOOKING AT. YOU KNOW FOR TRYING
TO- ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
REHABILITATE AND- YOU KNOW BE A
CONTRIBUTING MEMBER OF SOCIETY
AND- A WHOLE OTHER AREA-
CRIMINAL JUSTICE. THAT I WANT
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND. HOW THIS
IS IMPACTING THE SPACES WELL-
AND IT YOU KNOW IT'S A IT'S A-
BIT THE POLICY IMPLICATIONS ARE
ARE SIMILAR. FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO.
REHABILITATE AND- AND STOP.
DOING THESE CRIMES- SO IT'S
WORTHY OF THE CONVERSATION. I
MEAN IT'S WE CAN ALL BE VERY
OFFENDED BY THE BEHAVIOR- BUT
WE'RE WE'VE BEEN PUSHING THE
STATE. IN IN ONE DIRECTION FOR
REASON I REALLY WANTED TO- AND
YOU BOTH HAVE AND I THINK THE
AUTHOR. HAS DONE A REALLY GOOD
JOB OF EXPLAINING. THE
DIFFERENCE AND THE DISTINCTION
IN THIS SITUATION AND WITH THIS
TYPE OF PROBATION. FROM WHAT WE
WERE PERHAPS GOING AFTER WITH
AB NINETEEN FIFTY THANK YOU.
PALMER COULD QUESTION A GOOD
INFORMATION FOR ALL OF US TO BE
AWARE OF. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM OUR COLLEAGUES. COMMENTS
THE CONCERNS. RIGHT DO YOU HAVE
A MOTION ON THE BILL. FOR THE
MOTION AND A SECOND. QUITE A
FEW VOICES SECATEURS- WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN DISASTER I'VE A THANK
YOU. I'M SECTOR PLEASE COLOR OF
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA HI DOLLY DOLLY I
BENNETT. BENNETT I BIGELOW
BIGELOW I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I
CRISTINA GARCIA. KALRA LEVINE
HI LEVINE AYE MERE SU CHI. NO
WHEN I RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS
SALAS I SMITH SMITH I'D PADILLA
VIA PADILLA I WARD WARD I.
THANK YOU LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON YOU
WANT TO GO BACK TO FIVE MISTER
COLLIER AND FIVE- A YES THANK
YOU SEE WHICH WHICH- WHICH
NUMBER WAS THAT. EIGHTY THREE
SEVEN. YES SO. HAPPY TO PRESENT
AB THREE SEVEN NINE AND THIS
WAS A YOU KNOW- I THINK. TO ME
WHAT SEEMS TO BE AN OVERSIGHT
IN THE LAW- AND THAT CAME TO
LIGHT FOR ME WHEN WORKING WITH
A- LOCAL TRIBAL COUNCIL WHO IS
LOOKING TO TAKE OVER A
CONSERVATION EASEMENT- IN MY
DISTRICT. ONLY TO FIND THAT
UNDER THE CURRENT RULES
ACTUALLY TRIBE TRAVEL
GOVERNMENTS ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
BE AN EASEMENT HOLDER- AND SO-
EIGHTY THREE SEVENTY NINE WOULD
WOULD CORRECT THAT OVERSIGHT-
THAT PREVENTS THAT CURRENTLY
PREVENTS ACQUISITION OF
CONSERVATION LANDS- BY
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES- ASIDE AT ASK FOR YOUR-
SUPPORT OF CLEAN UP THIS.
OVERSIGHT AND ALLOWING- YOU
KNOW. CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
PEOPLE- WHO WHO PROBABLY KNOW A
WHOLE LOT ABOUT STEWARDSHIP AND
CONSERVATION- TO TAKE OVER
MANAGEMENT OF THESE
CONSERVATION. EASEMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU SIR THE OPRAH
WITNESSES- FOR THIS. I DO HAVE
A I THINK WITNESSES- THAT MAY
BE ON THE PHONE YES SORRY YOU
HAVE VOTED SANDRA NIGHT- AFTER
MID SHIP TO TRIBE OF CHICO
RANCHERIA. AND PERHAPS FRANK
MOLINA- AS WELL THANK YOU
PLEASE CLOSELY. AFTERNOON-
THIS- PARCEL THAT WE ARE
LOOKING TO ACQUIRE IT IS- WE
HAVE A DEEP CONNECTION TO THIS
PARCEL WE CURRENTLY USE IT TO
COLLECT OUR WILL FOR BASKET
MAKING. IT IS IT WITHIN ONE
MILE OF A SACRED VILLAGE SITE.
AND WE JUST THE MAGIC TO TRY
THIS BASED IN CHICO WHERE
PHILLY RECOGNIZED TRIBE WE HAVE
OVER SIX HUNDRED MEMBERS. AND
THIS IS ONE OF OUR SACRED
WATERS THAT WE WOULD LOVE TO
TAKE OVER AND TEND TO IT WITH
OUR TRADITIONAL ECOLOGICAL
KNOWLEDGE- AND SO WE JUST SEE
THIS AS A FIX. THAT WOULD BE
THE THAT TROUBLED GOVERNMENTS
WERE LEFT OFF THIS PUBLIC
RESOURCE CODE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU WITH
THE CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS- FRANK
MOLINA- JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
VICE CHAIRMAN'S- TESTIMONY-
MAKE MYSELF AVAILABLE AS OR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE SO THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR. MANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO ADD ON IN SUPPORT.
FRANKLIN ON BEHALF OF THE
SEMINAL BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
OF THE SENATE IS BANISHING
MISSION IS IN SUPPORT THANKS
SIR. ANYONE ELSE. OKAY ANYONE
IN THE VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM.
NOPE ALL RIGHT NOW ON THE PHONE
LINE MISTER MODERATOR. BECAUSE
IN SUPPORT OF PLEASE ENJOY MY
CHART SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
A TO IN OUR QUEUE. THANK YOU.
HOW WILL START WITH NUMBER ONE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS CAN DELFINO
REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS STUFF. THANK YOU THE NEXT
PERSON. WELL NOW GO TO NUMBER
ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE OF THEM YOU DON'T KNOW IF
THE- WITHOUT ONE CALIFORNIANS
WORKS. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. I GOT. AT THIS TIME OR NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR THANK YOU ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION ANY WITNESSES HERE
IN OPPOSITION ON THE LINE OR IN
THE ROOM. OKAY VIDEO CONFERENCE
ROOM. AND NOW TO YOU MISTER
MODERATOR AND ONE. IN
OPPOSITION. AND IF YOU'RE NOW
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ARE NONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE MR TANK YOU
THANK YOU WE WILL OFFER YOU
BACK TO THE BODY HERE ANY
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS FOR THE
AUTHOR THE BILL. IS THERE A
MOTION TO MOVE THE ITEM. FOR
THE MOTION AND A SECOND. AND
DIFFERENT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK THE
VICE CHAIRWOMAN AND THE TRIBE
FOR BRINGING THIS. ISSUE TO MY
ATTENTION I WAS SURPRISED WHEN
I FIRST HEARD IT BUT WE'VE GOT
AN OPPORTUNITY I THINK TO MAKE
A GOOD FIX YOURSELF SHARE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS MEASURE. MY
KID DOESN'T HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION OFF BROKE UP.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA
HI EDUARDO GARCIA I DALI. DALI
I BENNETT. BENNETT I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN
I CRISTINA GARCIA. KALRA LEVIN.
LEVINE AYE MERE SU CHI. NO ONE.
KNEW WHEN I RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
SALAS SALAS I SMITH. SMITH IV A
PRODUCER VIA PADURA I WARD WORD
I ALL RIGHT WE'LL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS HAD ON
THANK YOU FOR YOUR THIRD FINAL
BILL. OKAY OUR LAST ISSUE
ANOTHER IMPORTANT WATER ISSUE
IN THE STATE A CONSOLIDATION OF
WATER SYSTEM- I WEAR THAT MAY.
BE NECESSARY AB EIGHT FIFTY I
WOULD EXTEND THE SUNSET DATE ON
AN EXISTING PILOT PROGRAM TO
ENCOURAGE THE VOLUNTARY
CONSOLIDATION. OF SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS IN THE CITIES OF EL
MONTE MONTEBELLO AND WILLOW'S-
I'VE WORKED ON THIS MEASURE
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON- IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE'RE ABLE TO
PASS AB TWO THREE THREE NINE.
AT THAT TIME- FROM FORTY THAT
STATUE DOES SUNSET ON JANUARY
ONE. I WHICH IS NOT PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT TIME FOR THE CITY OF
WILLOWS TO UTILIZE THE
STREAMLINED PROCESS. FOR THEIR
INTENDED- CONSOLIDATION SO
ASKING FOR YOUR HELP IN AND-
EXTENDING THAT SUNSET AND ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU WE HAVE- WITNESSES TO
WITNESSES FOR THE MEASURE- I
BELIEVE WE DO HAVE ON- WHEN
PEABODY THE CITY MANAGER OF THE
CITY OF LOS. I BELIEVE THAT- ON
THE FURTHER. YES SIR THANK YOU
MR GALLAGHER. I MEDICARE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GOING PEOPLE
I AM WITH THE MANAGER THE CITY
WELLS WELL ISN'T GOING COUNTY
ABOUT AN HOUR AND A HALF NORTH
OF SACRAMENTO WE HAVE
POPULATION A LITTLE OVER SIX
THOUSAND PEOPLE. THAT ARE
CONSIDERED TO BE A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY I'M
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE CINNAMON GALLAGHER IS AB
EIGHT FIFTY. THE ENTIRE
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS AND
WELLS ADVERSELY AFFECTED BY
CHROME SIX. AND IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THE CITY RESIDENTIAL
WATER PROVIDER CAL WATER I
RECEIVED A GRANT TO INSTALL THE
TREATMENT OF THE CHROME SIX
FOR. TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED HOMES
AND BUSINESSES WITHIN THE CITY
OF LOS. THE CITY HOWEVER HAD A
SMALL INDUSTRIAL- WATER SYSTEM
THAT HAS A FEW CONNECTIONS
CURRENTLY OUTSIDE OF THE CAL
WATER'S SYSTEM WHICH IS ROUGHLY
THIRTY SIX HUNDRED FEET- WE
WERE ABLE TO INSTALL- TWO
THOUSAND FEET OF WATERLINE WE
ARE IN THE- WE ARE STILL TRYING
TO GET A LAST SIXTEEN HUNDRED
FEET INSTALLED. SO RATHER THAN
TO BUILD. AN EXPENSIVE AND
DUPLICATIVE CHROME SIX WATER
TREATMENT CENTER- WE ASK FOR
YOUR- SUPPORT. AND APPROVAL OF
THIS A FIFTY SO WE CAN TRY TO
DO THE BEST WE CAN FOR OUR
COMMUNITY- THE CITY WILL ALWAYS
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FIFTY WE WILL. HELP TO
GUARANTEE OUR RESIDENTS ARE
SAFE DRINKING WATER WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
SUPPORT AB EIGHT FIFTY THANK
YOU THANK YOU WE HAVE. JUST IN
SCARBOROUGH. ALSO WITNESS. BE A
COUPLE. OF MISTER CHAIR YEAH
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE THANK SO
MUCH FOR NAME'S JEFF SCARR BY
MATT. CAN AFFAIRS AND GOVERNOR.
FOR CAL WATER WHICH HAS THE
PLEASURE OF BEING THE MINUTE
THE WATER SUPPLIER IN THE CITY
OF- CITY OF WILLOWS AND THAT
NUMBER OF OTHER COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE- WEREN'T
STRONG SUPPORTER OF EIGHTY
EIGHT FIFTY. I'D BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T TAKE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
GALLAGHER AND GIPSON FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE- THE
CODEPENDENT BECAUSE OU REALLY
SERVE TO HIGHLIGHT THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE FACED BY
NUMBER SMALL WATER PROVIDERS IN
THE STATE- ESPECIALLY THOSE IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. THE
THE WATER BOARD HAS ESTIMATED
THAT ABOUT TWENTY FIVE WILL BE
SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZED WATER
UTILITIES ARE AT RISK OF
COMPLETE FINANCIAL FAILURE-
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
THE SCALE NEEDED TO OVERCOME
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL STRESS.
BALL EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY DOESN'T
SOLVE ALL THESE PROBLEMS IT
SETS UP A METHOD BY WHICH WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO MODEL BEHAVIOR
AT THE FUTURE. ALLOWS US TO
RELIEVE SOME OF THAT PRESSURE
IN THE THREE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE IDENTIFIED IN THE BILL- AND
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE ABLE TO
WORK WITH- WITH THE CITY OF
WILLOWS ON THIS IMPORTANT
PROJECT MY LOOKING FORWARD TO
BE ABLE TO. HIGHLIGHT THAT
INTERCONNECTION WITH THEM- AND-
WE THINK THIS IS A GREAT
MEASURE WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH I APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO ADD ON. IT'S
OF. THE SPORT. IN IN THE
VIDEOCON. ROOM WE MOVE ONTO
THE- MODERATOR FOLLOWING. AND
LATER GERMAN- PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE ONE IN THE
QUEUE TO JUST BE A MOMENT THANK
YOU. AND SO WILL FIRST GO TO
LINE ONE FORTY ONE. ONE FORTY
ONE YOUR LINES OPEN. GARCIA AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
JOHNNY BANANA ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF MONTEBELLO IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT FIFTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE WAS
MODERATOR. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE MR THANK YOU
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND IT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THE ROOM. CONFERENCE ROOM. MISS
WATER ON THE PHONE LINE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. DR NOW
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. THIS TIME THERE ARE NONE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'LL BRING
BACK TO THE BODY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. TURNS ARE MOTION.
MOTION AND A SECOND BEING THAT-
LEARN ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WHICH I CLOSE AYE DISASTER AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
RIGHT SO MOST OF SECOND TO MOVE
THIS TO PROVISIONS DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. ROCCA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE EDUARDO
GARCIA HI AND WATER GARCIA HI
DOLLY. DOLLY I BENNETT BENNETT
I BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA
KALRA. LEVINE LEVINE AYE
MURATSUCHI WHEN I RUBIO RUBIO
AYE SALAS SALAS I SMITH SMITH I
COULD DO IT VIA PADUKA HI WARD
WARD I. THANK YOU ALL OPEN FOR
OTHER MEMBERS I DON'T JUST
PAUSE AND SAY THANK YOU MEMBERS
TO BE PRESENT FOR BEING
PATIENT- AS WE MOVE THROUGH THE
ATTENDANCE ALL CALLED NEXT
PRESENTER MISTER RIVAS HIS
COMPORTMENT TO BILLS.
HAVE YOU
MISTER CHAIR SMALLING'S. HAVE
BY OUR COLLEAGUE HERE MR SALAS
WILL JOIN ME IS HE'S A JOINT
AUTHORS ON THIS LEGISLATION AND
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE AND- THIS
COMMITTED TODAY AND YOU KNOW AS
AS AS GROUND WATER BECOMES LESS
AVAILABLE- IN THE STATE YOU
KNOW CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
IRRIGATED LAND AS WE KNOW-
INCLUDING HALF A MILLION ACRES-
IT'S BEEN ESTIMATED IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY ALONE WHAT TO
COME OUT OF AGRICULTURAL.
PRODUCTION AND UNFORTUNATE
SEEMS INEVITABLE AT THIS POINT
AND SO WITHOUT A PLAN OR A
STRATEGIC APPROACH TO ADDRESS-
SIGMA IMPACTED LAND CONVERSIONS
LAND WILL NO LONGER BE FARMED
AND WILL LAY- YOU KNOW- YOU
KNOW WITH- WITHOUT A PRIMARY
USE. AND SO- YOU KNOW SO THIS
IS CERTAINLY GONNA BECOME AN
ENVIRONMENTAL LIABILITY- AND
WILL EVENTUALLY NEED A REMEDY-
AND SO YOU KNOW THIS
LEGISLATION HERE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO FIVE TWO- WILL INSTEAD IS
SURE THAT WE'RE APPROACHING
THIS ISSUE MORE STRATEGICALLY.
BY WORKING TO REPURPOSE IDLED
OR FALLOW LAND IN WAYS THAT
BENEFIT OUR ECONOMY. AND OUR
AND ARE- ENVIRONMENT LOCALLY
REGIONALLY AND SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL IT PROPOSES TO CREATE
A PILOT PROGRAM THAT WOULD-
PROVIDE SOME GRANTS TO LOCAL
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES TO COUNTIES AND TO AND
TO- OTHERS TO PRO ACTIVELY
CONVERT LANDON TOLD ME WILDLIFE
HABITAT GROUNDWATER RECHARGE.
RANGELAND OR OTHER USES- AND SO
THIS BILL ENJOYS BROAD SUPPORT
FROM ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS FROM-
FROM- FROM BUSINESS FROM WATER
AGENCIES AND MANY MANY OTHERS-
IT'S A WITH THAT INVITE OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM. SUCH A VALLEY
PHYSICAL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AB DOES
YOUR CALL PRESENTS WITH SOMEONE
MEMBER RIVAS ON ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO FIFTY TWO AS YOU GUYS KNOW
AND WE'VE HEARD IN THIS
COMMITTEE IN PREVIOUS YEARS
CIGNA IS GONNA HAVE A HUGE
IMPACT NOT ONLY ON THE CENTRAL
VALLEY BUT A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA- WITH
CRAFTING THIS BILL WOULD WE
WOULD SPEND A COUPLE OF YEARS
IN THE MAKING. BUT WE BELIEVE
THIS IS A GOOD WIN WIN THIS IS
A WIN FOR THE ENVIRONMENTALISTS
THIS IS A WIN FOR THE- FARMERS
AND FOR AGRICULTURE WHAT
THEY'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE GONNA
HAVE THIS PILOT PROGRAM THAT WE
CAN USE HAVE SOME BENEFICIAL
USES THINGS LIKE CREATING PARKS
OUR COMMUNITY RECREATION
CENTERS- DRYLAND FARMING
RESTORING FLOOD PLAINS AND
HABITATS CREATING RAGE LAND.
AND SOME OF THE PROJECTS THAT
I'VE SEEN IS A WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION SO WE SEE THIS AS
A WIN WIN- MOVING FORWARD IN
THIS IS ANTICIPATION OF THE BIG
AFFECT THAT SO IT WAS GOING TO
HAVE AN RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. C. HAVE
BUT- TO WHAT ARE ONE AND HATED
DIRECTOR OF WESTERN WATER
RESILIENT ESCAPE ON THE
TELEPHONE LINE TO LASKER TO
PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON EIGHTY
TWO FIFTY TWO I AM MANHATTAN
WITH ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
THE SPONSOR OF THE CELL. WE'RE
HERE TODAY BECAUSE CENTER
VALLEY HAS REACHED A FORK IN
THE ROAD ON ONE PASS WITHOUT
MEASURES LIKE AB TWO FIFTY TO
THE VALLEY COULD BECOME A
HAPHAZARD PATCHWORK OF DUSTY
FIELD WITH INVASIVE WEEDS IN
PASSED. FURTHER IMPAIRING
ALREADY POOR AIR QUALITY AND
PUTTING MANY FARM WORKERS OUT
OF WORK ON ANOTHER PATH THE
VALLEY COULD TRANSFORM INTO A
WATER RESILIENT AGRICULTURAL
REGION RIDING AMID A MOSAIC OF
VIBRANT NEW LAND USES. LIKE
HABITAT CORRIDORS WILDLIFE
FRIENDLY RECHARGE AREAS OR
OUTDOOR. RECREATIONAL SPACES
FOR FAMILIES. THIS BILL CAN
HELP MOVE THE DOWN THIS PASS.
THE CANNIBAL GRAMMAR MANAGEMENT
ACT OR SIGMA WHEN ACTED IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO ADDRESS
CRITICAL GROUNDWATER OVERDRAFT
WHICH CAUSED PLAN THINK DAMAGED
INFRASTRUCTURE AND DRIED UP
COMMUNITY DRINKING WELL DURING
THE LAST DROUGHT. SIGMA IS
CRUCIAL TO BUILDING LONG TERM
WATER SUSTAINABILITY. ONE
UNFORTUNATE REALITY OF THIS
TRANSITION IS THAT A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
AGRICULTURAL LAND ASSEMBLY
DECIDE TO GIVE SOMEBODY. WILL
NEED TO BE TAKEN OUT OF
PRODUCTION OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
DECADES. THIS WILL BE A
CHALLENGE EXACERBATED BY MORE
FREQUENT DROUGHTS LIKE WHAT
WE'RE EXPERIENCING NOW. AB TWO
FIFTY TO TURN THIS CHALLENGE
INTO A NEW OPPORTUNITY FOR
FARMERS AND COMMUNITIES. FIVE
SEVENTEEN THE MULTI BENEFIT
LANDRY PURPOSING INCENTIVE
PROGRAM THIS BILL WILL ENABLE
FARMERS TO RECEIVE PAYMENTS FOR
VOLUNTARILY REPURPOSE SAYING
SOME OF THEIR LAND TO PRODUCE
ECOSYSTEM. RECREATIONAL AND
OTHER BENEFITS THAT THE VALLEY
AND ITS COMMUNITIES NEED AND
WANT. AB TWO FIFTY TWO IS THE
MOST PROMISING WAY TO TAKE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY DOWN A NEW PATH
TOWARD A MORE RESILIENT FUTURE
FOR PEOPLE AND WILDLIFE. WE'D
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
RIVAS AND SALAS FOR THEIR
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN IPHONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WHEN
ASKED IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
ROOM. WISHING TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF THE MEASURE. SEE ANYONE. BOB
PHONE LINES MISTER MODERATOR.
FOXCONN INTENTLY GERMAN AND- IN
GERMAN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
LINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE ABOUT FIVE IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU. WE'LL START WITH
NUMBER ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON THAT YOUR
SHARED MEMBERS OF JENNIFER
BEING TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK ONE OF THE MIDDLE
ABOUT ONE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
NEXT TO BE NUMBER ONE FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MARK THANKS TO
MAKE ON BEHALF OF SUSTAINABLE
CONSERVATION IN SUPPORT. NEXT
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE NUMBER ONE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MARK
HENLEY WITH CALIFORNIA WATER
FILE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
TO BE NUMBER ONE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS AMANDA MONACO WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND SUPPORT.
AND NEXT OVER THE NUMBER ONE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA MARKETS
ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN FARMLAND
TRUST AND THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AGRICULTURE NETWORK AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AT THE TIME
OR NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU SIR ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE. ANYONE WISHING TO
MEASURE IN THE ROOM. NOW GO
BACK TO YOU MISTER MODERATOR
ANYONE CALLING IN TO OPPOSE THE
MEASURE. AND THOSE IN
OPPOSITION THE PHONE LINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THERE ARE NONE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MR CARE
BRING THE ITEM BACK TO THE BODY
YEARS. QUESTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I WOULD
LIKE TO WHAT COMPLEMENT THE
AUTHORS- OF. I'VE SPENT
CONSIDERABLE TIME ON THE
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCY- AND WRESTLING WITH THIS
VERY ISSUE AND LAND BEING TAKEN
OUT OF PRODUCTION- I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T GET THIS QUESTION TO YOU
IN ADVANCE BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK. MOSTLY FOR THE RECORD.
THESE CONVERSIONS. WHAT'S THE
TIME FRAME ON THE CONVERGENCE
OF THESE PERMIT CONVERSIONS ON
THESE TEMPORARY CONVERSION SO.
COULD YOU HELP THE PUBLIC
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD. WELL I YOU KNOW- I'M
UNDER THE IMPRESSION THAT THIS-
THESE PRODUCTIVE AG LANDS-
SHOULD THEY BE CONVERTED IT'LL
BE- FOR- I WOULD I WOULD
IMAGINE IN. PERPETUITY I THANK
THANKS IT'S A QUESTION CAME UP
OF LATE LAST EVENING AT SOME
SOMEBODY REGION WENT AND ASKED
A QUESTION- BUT I DO THINK IT
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE AND WE
HAVE- FARMERS IN IN MY DISTRICT
ARE- TRYING TO DECIDE. WHICH
PLAN IS GOING TO BE BE
FOLLOWED- AND THIS IS A TOOL
THAT WILL SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER
THE COST FOR THE AGENCY TO TRY
TO CREATE THOSE INCENTIVES- I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS AND
CONGRATULATE YOU AND- YOU'RE
CALLING FOR A RECKONING FOR
WORDS. WELL I- APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND- AGREE WITH YOU
THIS IS A YOU KNOW- IT'S A TOOL-
AND CERTAINLY COULD YOU KNOW
HELP- YOU KNOW. WITH THE
TRANSITION MELANIE OBVIOUSLY OF
A PAINFUL ONE FOUR FOUR- YOU
KNOW WITHIN AGRICULTURE BUT
CERTAINLY COULD YOU KNOW HAVE
THAT BENEFIT FOR- YOU KNOW THAT
REGION OR- YOU KNOW THAT AREA.
YEAH THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS CONTRA MOVE A MOVE
THE RECOMMENDED ACTION TOMORROW
THANK YOU SIR. IT'S VETERANS
MOTION. THE SECOND MISTER THE
DO A- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS UP
MATTER FOR DRY- SEE THE KIND OF
STRIKING OF THE BALANCE RIGHT.
OR IS THIS IS THE READING OF
THE NEEDLE IN TERMS OF ISSUES
THAT ARE QUITE- QUITE DIFFICULT
TO HANDLE SIGMA AS THEIR MUCH
ANTICIPATED- POLICY THAT WILL
BE GETTING ROLLED OUT SOON AND
WE'LL SEE WHAT. THE
IMPLICATIONS OF ALL THOSE PLANS
OR SOME IT WILL BE SOON AND I
KNOW THAT OUR FARMING COMMUNITY
WAS OF VERY VERY INTERESTED IN
BEING ENGAGED AND PREVIEW
BRINGS FOR I'D LIKE TO ADD ON
AS- SO WHAT DO WITH YOUR-
PERMISSION TO BOTH OF YOU AND-
NOW WE DO HAVE A MOTION THE
SECOND DOES HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION SAUCE FOR ROCA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA HI DOLLY. DOLLY
I BENNETT. BENNETT I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN HI
CRISTINA GARCIA KALRA LEVIN
LEVINE AYE MERE SU CHI NORMAN
NEWMAN AYE RUBIO RUBIO AYE
SALAS SALAS I SMITH. SMITH I'D
BE ABLE TO DO IT THE OPRAH DO
OUTSIDE WARD WARD I. THE
STRUCTURE AND ALSO LIKE TO ADD
ON AS A CO AUTHOR OF FICTION
THANK YOU THAT. CITING YES. FOR
THE CONSIDERATION AND
ENGAGEMENT ON- THIS BILL. AND
THE FOLLOWING MY APPOINTMENT TO
SERVE AS CHAIR OF- THE
ASSEMBLY- THE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE THIS PAST
SEPTEMBER. I EMBARKED ON A TWO
MONTH STATEWIDE AGRICULTURE
TOUR OF MEETINGS AND SITE
VISITS AND MY GOAL WAS TO
ENGAGE WITH STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS
OUR STATE- AND GATHER
PERSPECTIVES ON THE NEEDS OF-
OF CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE AND
PRODUCTIVE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY. YOU KNOW IT'S OVER
TWO MONTHS I MET WITH
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY
STAKEHOLDERS. I VISITED OVER
FIFTY SITES- I WOULD HAVE DONE
MORE BUT OBVIOUSLY IS DURING
THE SURGE OF. OF US PANDEMIC IN
SO WE HAD TO RESCHEDULE A LOT
OF THESE VISITS. BUT ALL OF OUR
VISITS INCLUDED FARMERS-
FARMING AGRICULTURAL WORKERS-
INDUSTRY UNION LEADERS
ENVIRONMENTALISTS SCIENTISTS
AND RESEARCHERS FROM UC DAVIS
AND UCLA. A COUPLE WEEKS AGO ON
NATIONAL AG DAY MY OFFICE
RELEASED A REPORT OUT FROM OUR
AG TOUR THE- YOU KNOW IN IN
THIS REPORT- IT WAS SENT TO ALL
OF. YOUR OFFICES. THIS REPORT
INCLUDES FINDINGS AND POLICY
IDEAS BASED ON THE
CONVERSATIONS IN THE LEVEL OF
ENGAGEMENT WE HAD. AND SO THIS
LEGISLATION- HERE ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE OH THREE- MARICULTURE
PILOT PROGRAM. IT WAS INSPIRED
BY A VISIT I HAD A MEETING I
HAD I DIDN'T AQUACULTURE
OPERATION AT THE PORT OF SAN
DIEGO. AND IT WAS AT THAT VISIT
WERE I LEARNED OF NEW RESEARCH
IN INCREASING BODY OF RESEARCH.
SHOWING THAT SHELLFISH AND
SEAWEED FARMS OR OPERATIONS IF
DONE RIGHT. IF THE RIGHT
PRACTICES ARE DEPLOYED IN THE
RIGHT PLACES. THEY CAN ACTUALLY
DELIVER RESTORATIVE US AND
BENEFITS FOR OCEAN HEALTH. IT
CAN BE A VERY EFFECTIVE TOOL TO
FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE. AND IS
ONE OF THE MOST SUSTAINABLE
FORMS OF FOOD PRODUCTION ON OUR
PLANET SO UNFORTUNATELY AS I
LEARNED THE BIGGEST CONSTRAINT
TO EXPANDING MARICULTURE HERE
AND OUR STATE IS CURRENTLY AND
HAS ALWAYS BEEN THE PERMITTING
PROCESS. THE PERMITTING PROCESS
IN OUR STATE IS EXHAUSTIVE IT
IS TIME CONSUMING. AND IT IS
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE. IN
FACT HERE CALIFORNIA IS
EXPONENTIALLY EASIER. TO OBTAIN
APPROVAL FOR A NEW OIL WELL.
THEN IT IS THE FARM SHELLFISH
OR SEA WEED. CALLAGY AND WILL-
WILL TYPICALLY APPROVING OIL
OUT WITHIN TEN DAYS. WITH
USUALLY NO- NO NOTICE THE
PUBLIC. NOT A PERIOD TO MAKE
COMMENTS OR PROJECT SPECIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW. NOW THE
ABSOLUTE MOST OPTIMISTIC
SCENARIO FOR MARICULTURE. IS
THREE TO FOUR YEARS PER PROJECT.
BUT MORE REALISTICALLY IT COULD
TAKE OVER A DECADE. THAT'S ALL
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE DATA IN
THE PAST TEN YEARS ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND NEW OIL WELLS HAD
BEGUN OPERATION IN CALIFORNIA.
IN THAT SAME TIME FRAME EXACTLY
ZERO. ZERO NEW SHELLFISH OR SEE
WE FARMS HAD BEGUN OPERATION.
AND SO THAT IS WHY THIS
LEGISLATION PROPOSES TO CREATE
A PILOT PROGRAM. DETEST AN
ALTERNATIVE MORE STRAIGHT
FORWARD APPROACH THE
CALIFORNIA'S MARICULTURE
PERMITTING. AND IT WOULD DO SO
WITHOUT SACRIFICING THE HIGH
INBOUND ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS
THE INDUSTRY CURRENTLY ACHIEVES.
THIS LEGISLATION REQUIRES THAT
CALIFORNIA'S LEADING REGULATORY
AGENCIES FOR. OCEAN FARMING FOR
MARICULTURE. TO COLLABORATIVELY
WORK TOGETHER IN ADOPTED THE
REGULATIONS FOR THIS PROPOSED
PILOT PROGRAM. PROVIDING THEM
WITH THE DISCRETION TO IDENTIFY
THE RIGHT MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
TO BE DEPLOYED. TO IDENTIFY
ALLOWED SPECIES FOR BOTH
RESTORATION AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTION. AT TO DESIGNATE THE
RIGHT PLACES OR PHYSICAL
LOCATIONS FOR POTENTIAL
OPERATIONS. THE RESULT I HOPE
IS THAT THERE WILL BE AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
NUMERICAL TRIP PROJECTS HERE IN
OUR STATE WHICH I I'VE WHICH
WHICH WHICH I'VE SAID WOULD
YIELD SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS TO
OUR STATE IN TERMS OF FOOD
PRODUCTION. ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE BENEFITS TO
OUR ENVIRONMENT NOT TO MENTION
AS I LEARNED IN AS- A STUDY-
THAT WAS JUST RELEASED ABOUT A
MONTH AGO- CONFIRMED. THAT THIS
RED SEA WEED WHEN INCORPORATED
INTO THE FEET OF CATTLE. WE
SHOWN TO REDUCE METHANE.
EMISSIONS FROM CATTLE BURPS AND.
AND OTHER THINGS BY OVER 80%
OVER 80% BY ADDING JUST A SMALL
AMOUNT OF SEA WEED TO THEIR
FEET. AND SO WITH ME HERE TO-
PROVIDE SOME TESTIMONY IS TERRY
SAWYER CO FOUNDER OF HOG ISLAND
OYSTER COMPANY. AND DR- HOLLY
FOR A LOOK ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURE. OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY THANK YOU MEASURE.
THANK YOU. AND I BELIEVE
THEY'RE BOTH CLOUT COLLEEN
INSULT PEOPLE STATE. EIGHT TO
PROVIDE THE TESTIMONY TUESDAY
IN SUPPORT FOR THE AB THREE OH
THREE. IT'S BEEN AN HONOR TO
BUILD OUR BUSINESS AND PROVIDE
GOOD HEALTHY LOCAL FOOD TO OUR
COMMUNITY WHILE BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE JOB OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OVER THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE. PRE
PANDEMIC. WE'VE SEEN THAT WE
CAN GROW OYSTERS IN A WAY THAT
IS COMPATIBLE WITH AND EVEN
HELPS ADVANCE THE CONSERVATION
OF OUR VEHICLE DEMOLISHED BAY
AND WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
ALMOST FORTY YEARS. BUT THERE'S
BEEN MANY CHALLENGES THE
CURRENT PERMITTING THE LEASING
THE REGULATORY SYSTEM IS SIMPLY
NOT DESIGNED FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO DO BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE. WE'RE WILLING AND
EAGER TO MEET THE HIGHEST
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS IN THE
NATION. WE ABSOLUTELY DEPEND ON
COLD WATER TO SURVIVE COLD
CLEAN WATER TO SURVIVE. BUT A
POOR MEETING THOSE STANDARDS WE
WANT TO BE TREATED JUST LIKE
ANY OTHER BUSINESS WE CAN'T
KEEP JUMPING THROUGH NEW AND
DIFFERENT HOOPS ALL THE TIME.
THERE'S SO MUCH INTEREST IN
SUSTAINABLE AMERICOLD SURE
AMONG THE NEXT GENERATION. BUT
AT THE RATE WE'RE GOING I'M
WORRIED THAT NONE OF THEM WILL
BE ABLE TO GET INTO THIS FIELD.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE SO SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS PROPOSED PILOT PROGRAM.
WE NEED TO FIND A PATHWAY FOR
THAT RETAINS ARE STRONG
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS. WHILE
LEADING WELL DESIGNED
OPERATIONS ACTUALLY GET INTO
THE WATER. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
EXTEND AN INVITATION TO ANYONE
ON THE COMMITTEE TO COME OUT
PER VISIT TO OUR OPERATIONS.
HERE ON SMALLEST BAY. AND TO
SEE WHAT WE'RE SO PROUD AND
CONFIDENT ABOUT. COURSE AFTER
THE PANDEMIC RESTRICTIONS
RELAXED ALLOWED TRAVEL. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY TODAY ON
AB THREE OH THREE. MY NAME IS
DR HOLLY LIKE AND I'M AN
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SANTA
BARBARA WHERE THIRTY IMPACT IN
INTERACTIONS WITH AQUACULTURE
WILD FISHERIES AND CLIMATE
CHANGE- I AM ALSO ONE OF THE
PRINCIPAL INVESTIGATORS ON THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA AQUACULTURE ACTION
PLANS AS WELL. THE
COLLABORATORS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. WHILE NOW IN THE
BY LETTER THAT. OR FARMING AND
PARTICULARLY MARICULTURE IS A
RELATIVELY SMALL GIVEN ITS
POTENTIAL IN THE UNITED STATES
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA. BUT WHAT
NEW ACADEMIC WILL CONSERVATION
RESEARCH IS NOW SHOWING IS THAT
MIRACLE CURE DOES IN FACT HAVE
THE POTENTIAL TO NOT TO BENEFIT
PEOPLE BUT ALSO BENEFIT NATURE.
THE TICKET ALERTLY TRAIL S. S.
B. OKAY ON THE TYPE OF SKILL
MANAGEMENT AND GOAL OF THAT
PRODUCTION BUT THEM DIFFERENT
THAN FARMED OYSTERS AS WE HEARD
AND- WE CAN PROVIDE ECOSYSTEM
SERVICES. LIKE INCLUDING LOCAL
WATER QUALITY BRING SOME LEVEL
OF ACIDIFICATION AND EVEN HELP
CAPTURE CARBON. IMPORTANTLY IN
THE SYTEM AS A WHOLE CAN BE A
FOURTH OF THE OVERALL LOWER
IMPACT FOOD PRODUCTION MAIN
COMPARED TO OTHER FOOD SYSTEM
ESPECIALLY. UNDER BASS NINETEEN
FORMS MANAGEMENT PRACTICES. THE
UNITED STATES IS IN FACT THE
NUMBER ONE IMPORTING STEVEN
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD AND
CALIFORNIA ACCOUNTS FOR THE
LARGEST PROPORTION OF NATIONAL
PEOPLE'S CONSUMPTION AT ABOUT
14% OF THAT CONSUMPTION. WHICH
IS ONLY ANTICIPATED TO INCREASE
INTO THE FUTURE. THIS BILL JUST
BEGINS ADDRESSING THE NEED AND
POTENTIAL FOR MORE EQUITABLE
ACCOUNTING THE CALIFORNIA YOU
CAN PRODUCTION CONSUMPTION
CENTER GOALS FOR THE FUTURE OF
MARICULTURE IN SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
THROUGH A PILOT PROCESS. AND
BEGIN TO ALIGN WEARING FARMING
WITHIN A CLIMATE CHANGE
MITIGATION AND ADAPTIVE
FRAMEWORK ESSENTIAL FOR MORE
RESILIENT PEOPLE SYSTEM
OVERALL. DOCSTOC THERE AND
WALDRON THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS- ON THE
CLIENT SIDE OF THINGS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE
IN THE ROOM. WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF MEASURE. OKAY SO
NO ONE CAN SEE ANYONE UP ON THE
VIDEOCON SO WE'LL GO TO THE
PHONE THIS FROM. BECAUSE IT'S
SUPPORT. TO THE MY- AND PLEASE
IN JOHN IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF
THE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE TO IN
THE QUEUE. PLEASE PROCEED. AND
WE'LL START WITH- LINE ONE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR STERN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JOHNSON PLAYED ABOUT
THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THREE OH THREE
AND ALSO JUST LIKE TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THEAUTHOR OUT OF SUMMER
RIVAS FOR THE KIND WORDS IN HIS
OPENING STATEMENT. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALL ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. WE CURRENTLY HAVE NO
OTHERS IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR JEFF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW WILL BE ASKING IF
THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TO THE MEASURE.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WASHINGTON
AFTERNOON UP. I AM A WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU- SHARE
GARCIA AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I'M LINDA KROP CHIEF COUNSEL OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
CENTER TESTING ON BEHALF OF THE
GROUPS THAT SUBMITTED AN
OPPOSED LETTER. MAKE KNOWLEDGE
THE STATE'S INTEREST IN
SUSTAINABLE AQUACULTURE HOWEVER
WE BELIEVE THIS BILL IS
PREMATURE AND UNNECESSARY THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL IS
WORKING ON AND OFF THE CULTURE
ACTION PLAN MULTIPLE STATE
AGENCIES ARE WORKING ON
AQUACULTURE PRINCIPLES A
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL MAILLET
FISH AND GAME COMMISSION HAVE
PREPARED AN AQUACULTURE
INFORMATION REPORT WHICH WILL
INFORM FURTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW. AND MOST RECENTLY
ACOSTA COMMISSION DEVELOPED A
PERMIT GUIDE FOR AQUACULTURE IN
CALIFORNIA THIS GUIDE WAS
MANDATED LESS THAN TWO YEARS
AGO BY SB TWO SIXTY TWO THE
PURPOSE OF THE GUY JUST TO
ASSIST APPLICANTS FOR MARINE
AQUACULTURE RESTORATION PROJECT
BY REDUCING DUPLICATIVE
OVERLAPPING INFORMATION
REQUIREMENTS INCREASING STATE
AND FEDERAL AGENCY COORDINATION
INCREASING REGULATORY CERTAINTY
AND REDUCING THE TIME AND COST
ASSOCIATED WITH SECURING A
COASTAL DEVELOPMENT PERMIT. THE
GUIDE INCLUDES DETAILED
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
PROCESS TIMELINE AND
REQUIREMENTS FOR APPLICATIONS
AS WELL AS THE ROLES OF VARIOUS
STATE AGENCIES AS SUCH IT
ENSURES. PROPER COORDINATION
AND EFFICIENCY. SHE WE BELIEVE
THAT AB THREE OH THREE WHAT
INVESTOR THE WORK BEFORE
DIFFICULT. WITH SB SIX TWO AND
WHAT ROB MULTIPLE AGENCIES OF
THEIR IMPORTANT REVIEW WITH
ALREADY IN PARTICULAR THE BILL
WOULD ELIMINATE THE COASTAL
COMMISSION'S AUTHORITY DESPITE
THE AGENCY'S PREPARATION OF THE
GUIDE. AND THE FACT THAT THE
COMMISSION HAS A VERY EFFICIENT
HUNDRED REVIEW PROCESS. IN FACT
THE AVERAGE REVIEW PERIOD FOR
COASTAL DEVELOPMENT PERMIT IS
ONLY FOUR AND A HALF MONTHS.
AND THE COMMISSION ISSUED OR
UPDATED APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
SEVEN PERMITS FOR AQUACULTURE
OPERATIONS JUST OVER THE PAST
SIX YEARS. WITH MORE THAN 95%
PROCESS AS ADMINISTRATIVE OR
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS. GIVEN
THE STATE'S RECENT PROGRESS IN
COMPLIANCE WITH SB TWO SIXTY
TWO I RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU YEAH MONTHS SO
WE HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION ASHLEY
EAGLE GIPSON. I CAN YOU HEAR ME
OK YES THIS WILL SEE. WONDERFUL
SACRAMENTO GARCIA HONORABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ASHLEY WILL AGAIN AND I AM THE
CONSERVATION DIRECTOR WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTION COMMITTEE
OF WEST MARIN. I'M SPEAKING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE GREAT
SUPPLEMENT AND IMPOSE LETTER ON
MARCH TWENTY SIX. WE OPPOSE THE
BILL FOR MANY REASONS INCLUDING
THE BILL'S FAILURE TO
PRIORITIZE CAREFUL
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW THE LARGE
UNPRECEDENTED PILOT AREA
PROPOSED A LIMITED REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT OVER THE PILOT AREA
AND THE POTENTIAL CONFLICTS
WITH OTHER STATEWIDE EFFORTS.
REGARDING ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
EXTREMELY SHORT REVIEW TIMELINE
WHICH APPEAR AT THE COMPLEX BUT
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT OR CEQA
REQUIREMENTS THERE IS NO SIMPLE
EXEMPTION FOR PILOT PROJECTS.
ADEQUATE AN INDIVIDUALIZED
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW IF NOT
POSSIBLE IN FOUR MONTHS OR TWO
MONTHS FOR STATE GOVERNMENTS
HAVE LEASES WHICH HAVE VERY
LIMITED OVERSIGHT UNDER THE
BELT. IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA ESTUARIES AND
COASTAL WATERS ARE ALREADY
FACING OCEAN ACIDIFICATION
BIODIVERSITY LOSS IN C. LEVEL
RISE AND OTHER THREATS
DIRECTING CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF
ANY TYPE IN DEVELOPMENT MUST BE
CLOSELY CONSIDERED. ALONGSIDE
OTHER CITING. BOTH AREAS ARE.
LARGE APPROXIMATELY TIMES THAN
THE AREA THAT IS CURRENTLY
BEING. IN THE STATE PROPER
CULTURE WHICH IS NOT THE SAME
AS WHAT AREA THAT'S FULLY
LEASED. HYLA AREAS ARE ALSO
SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER IN SIZE
AND LONGER IN DURATION SIMILAR
PROJECTS AND OTHER EAST COAST
STATES. COMPARE TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED ACRES ON A TWELVE YEAR
PERIOD YOU LASSEN ONE ACRE AND
ONE TO THREE YEARS FOR SOME OF
THOSE OTHER EXAMPLES. AND WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THE PILOT PROCESS
ENDS IN TWENTY THIRTY SIX OR
ONE OF THE PILOT PROJECTS ON
SUCCESSFUL WITHOUT ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT FOR FUNDING FOR CLEAN
UP COSTS. THE BILL ALSO
APPEARED TO CONFLICT WITH THE
STATE AND FEDERAL AFRICAN
BILLION A THIRTY BY THIRTY FIVE
DIVERSITY EFFORTS. THIS BILL
DOES NOT REPRESENT THE BEST
INTERESTS OF CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS PROTECTION OF OUR
PRICE LOOK CLOSER RESPONSES.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ENCOURAGES
OUT NOW AND THE SPELL- I'M ALSO
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOW WE'LL
MOVE ON TO FOLKS IN THE ROOM.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE THE
BILL. SEE NO ONE ANYONE THE
BILL ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND SECOND MRS REESE RUBIO- ON
THE- I NEED TO HEAR THEM ACCORD
YEAH IF WE'RE MOVING PAST THAT
WE'RE GOING TO- GIVES ME TO IN
OPPOSITION- ON THE PHONE LINE
THAT'S WHO ARE I'M ASKING THE
MODERATOR NOW TO A QUEUE IN.
EVERY STORY. AND LATELY GERMAN
ON THE PHONE LINE IF YOU'RE
AND- OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY OF ONE IN A
QUEUE THANK YOU. I WILL GO TO
NUMBER ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ONE OF THE
MILANO- WITH PART OF ON
CALIFORNIA NOT IN A POSITION
WHERE TWEENER- WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE- O
ADDRESS SOME OF OUR CONCERNS
WERE CERTAINLY CONCERNED WITH A
LOT OF THE ISSUES RAISED- WITH
FOLKS IN YEAH THAT ARE OPPOSING
THE BILL- SPECIFICALLY THE
SCOPE AND SCALE THE PROGRAM. IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO SEE
ADDRESS- AND LIKE I SAID WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU FATHER'S OFFICE TO GET IT
RIGHT I'VE DONE RIGHT- STYLE.
NEXT CALL. AND AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MR THANK
YOU VERY I THINK THAT'S WHAT I
MEANT TO SAY THAT I HAVE A LIST
OF- OTHER THAN OPPOSITION OF
THE PERMIT TIME FOR THAT YES IF
YOU LIKE TO STATE THAT THE-
LIST FOR THE RECORD. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND SO. ACTUALLY
WILL GET WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
ACTION COMMITTEE OF WEST MARIN
I ALREADY. SPOKE AND THEN ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS WE OPPOSE AB
THREE A THREE. FAMILY PARKER
HEAL THE BAY SUSAN JORDAN
CALIFORNIA COASTAL PROTECTION
NETWORK. SHE HAGENS COAST WALK
OR CALIFORNIA COASTAL TRAIL
ASSOCIATION. MARTUCCI REFERENCE
OF THE EARTH ROSANNA MARINI ALL
NORTHWEST ATLANTIC MARINE
ALLIANCE BRANDEN DAWSON SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA. RIGHT NOW WITH
THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY AND THE AND FINAL
DEFENSE CENTER AND WENT ACROSS
PARTY SPELL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU- SEEING THAT
DON'T HAVE ANYONE ELSE- BECAUSE
ENOUGH. TO BRING BACK THE BODY
ANOTHER NUMBER FOLKS OF SOME
QUESTIONS. GREAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR- WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE WE KNOW THAT THERE IS
DEFINITELY A NEED FOR
SUSTAINABLE AQUACULTURE AND
IT'S TRICKY YOU HAVE AND I
THINK A LOT OF THE- INERTIA
THAT WE HAD- AND ESPECIALLY
OVER THE RECENT DECADES- BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE GET IT
RIGHT SO THAT WE DON'T. CREATE
A- AND THAT- NEGATIVE. ON THE
ENVIRONMENT ON THE QUALITY OF
THE PRODUCT THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO BE ABLE TO PRODUCE AND-
CERTAINLY- FOR BOTH A
CONSUMPTIVE- SEAFOOD- SELF THIS
IS ONE OF THOSE- THAT YOU KNOW
WE HAVE TO IMPORT US MOSTLY
FROM INTERNATIONAL RESOURCES-
WHY NOT BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO USE OUR- OUR- THE COAST
RIGHT OFF OF. THOSE MAILS
MARCOS IN A AND A MORE IN A
SMARTER WAY- BY THIS BILL FIRST
OF ALL I WANT APPRECIATE IS
NARROWED- TO SELFISH AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY TO HELP WHICH WE
KNOW IS- STARTED TO DISAPPEAR
OFF OUR COASTLINE IT'S
IMPORTANT WE CAN'T- THING
STREAMLINED TO BE ABLE TO
PROTECT BOTH OF THOSE. WELL
PROTECT THE RESOURCE AND THEN
ALSO BE ABLE TO GROW- ITSELF-
HAS CRAFTED RIGHT NOW I'VE GOT
A COUPLE OF ISSUES THAT I WANT
I WANT WANT TO GET TO YES AND I
JUST HOPE THAT I HAVE A
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON SOME OF
THESE- POINTS- ONE THIS PILOT
ESTABLISHES A MINIMUM NUMBER
AND THAT'S FIVE. OF THESE
TRACKS- BUT IT DOESN'T
ESTABLISH A MAXIMUM SO
THEORETICALLY THERE COULD BE
TWO HUNDRED OR MORE AND THEN
YOU GET TO A POINT OUT THAT IT
DOESN'T FEEL LIKE A PILOT
ANYMORE FEELS LIKE A FULL BLOWN
OPERATION- SO I'D ENCOURAGE YOU
TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT MAYBE THAT
REASONABLE MAXIMUM NUMBER
SHOULD BE- AND RELATED TO THAT
A DISTANCE REQUIREMENTS
BETWEEN. THE DIFFERENT TRACKS
SITE SO YOU DON'T HAVE FIVE
RIGHT NEXT TO EACH OTHER KIND
OF DEFEATS THE PURPOSE OF. A
THAT SECONDLY- IT REQUIRES
ENVIRONMENTAL I'M LOOKING FOR
MINIMAL ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS
BASICALLY STUDY ABOUT WHERE
THESE ARE GONNA BE LOCATED- AND
MAYBE THIS IS INFERRED BUT
NOTHING IN THE BILL RIGHT NOW
ACTUALLY WOULD- IT WOULD
REQUIRE- DONE. THE REGULATORY
AGENCY TO HAVE TO CONTINUE
ENVIRONMENTAL. MONITORING SO
THE LAST THING THAT WE WANT. IS
TO GO AHEAD AND GIVE THE- LIGHT
AND THEN HOW SOME. ENVIRONMENT
EFFECT THE SIR. AREA AN OFFER-
SO I REALLY WANT TO SEE THAT
STRENGTH AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE A REQUIREMENT FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL MONITORING-
CONDITIONS- THAT. ALSO WOULD-
THAT WOULD WOULD REQUIRE. A
TEMPORARY HALT. IN OPERATIONS
SHOULD WE SEE SOME SORT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL METRICS-
NEGATIVELY AFFECTED. DURING THE
COURSE OF ITS OPERATION-
THIRDLY- YOU KNOW SENSITIVE
WE'VE GOT. FULL APPRECIATION
FOR THE ROLE THAT OUR COASTAL
COMMISSION THE OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL AND OTHERS TO PLAY- BUT
I ALSO UNDERSTAND WINE TO BE
ABLE TO STREAMLINE THIS SORT OF
MINIMUM AND LIKE TO. BE ABLE TO
SEE- THE REQUIREMENT FOR DFW TO
CONSULT. WITH THESE TWO
ORGANIZATIONS OR OTHERS THAT
MAYBE. TO THEIR POINTS HAVE HAD
A LOT OF EFFORT A LOT OF
DEVELOPMENT. A LOT OF FUN AND
WE APPRECIATE THAT THOUGHT.
INTO THE WORK THAT WE HAVE FOR
AQUACULTURE- AND THEN- YOU KNOW
THROUGH THAT. IF YOU KNOW I
KNOW YOU'VE GOT SOME TIME
POINTS IN HERE ABOUT A REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE- IF THINGS
ARE LOOKING WELL AND- I KNOW
THE NEXT REPORT WILL COME OUT
IN THE YEAR TWENTY THIRTY- IF
THERE IS A DIFFERENT DATE. YOU
WANT TO LOOK AT THAT POSSIBLY
SHOW THAT PILOT IS WORKING ON A
VERY SMALL SCALE- THAT- THAT WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO REVISIT THIS
ISSUE AND- AND SEE ABOUT A
SCALING UP AGAIN BUT IF
EVERYTHING LOOKS GOOD. LIKE CB
HAD COMMITMENT TO WORK ON SOME
OF THESE ISSUES ABSOLUTELY NO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE CALMEST
AND AGREE WITH ALL THAT- YOU
SUGGESTED. YOU KNOW AND WE-
HAVE ENGAGES STAKEHOLDERS FROM
FROM- THE MOMENT WE INTRODUCED
THE BILL- AND- WE- WILL
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH THEM.
YOU KNOW BUT I THINK SOME OF
THESE SUGGESTIONS AT THE
COASTAL COMMISSION IS. CUT OUT
THAT'S NOT TRUE. THE
LEGISLATION IF YOU LOOK AT THE
LEGISLATION SPECIFICALLY
STATES. THAT IT- I BELIEVE
IT'S- THE DEPARTMENT OF- A
VISION WILDLIFE THAT THEY ARE
TO. CONSULT THAT THERE TO WORK
WITH ALL OF THE REGULATORY
AGENCIES- THAT- YOU KNOW WORK
IN THIS SPACE IN THIS AREA. OF
OCEAN FARMING. THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO WORK TOGETHER. TO
CREATE THIS MULTI AGENCY ADOPT
THESE MULTI AGENCY REGULATIONS
TO GOVERN THIS PILOT PROGRAM.
AND SO THAT'S WHY WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT C. CO YOU TALK ABOUT. THE
COASTAL ACT ALL OF THOSE.
ISSUES ARE TO BE- TAKE PLACE.
DURING THIS THIS. THIS
PROMULGATION OF THE REGULATIONS
THAT'S GONNA GOVERN THIS
PROGRAM. YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE MAKING THIS SHIFT
FROM A PROCESS THAT IS
DETERMINING THESE PROJECT ON A
PROJECT BY PROJECT BASIS- AND
TRYING TO CREATE THE
PARAMETERS. OF A- OF
OPERATIONS- SO THAT WAY IF YOU
HAVE- SOME POTENTIAL FARMERS
THE MEET THOSE THAT CRITERIA
BUT THEY DON'T- AND THAT'S WHY
YOU KNOW WE THE BILL SPECIFIES
ENFORCEMENT WHO WILL DO
ENFORCEMENT- AND THEN OBVIOUSLY
IT'S YOU KNOW BUT WE ARE
LEAVING IT TO ALL OF THE
REGULATORY AGENCIES THAT
CURRENTLY- MANAGE THIS PROCESS.
FOR PUTTING IT TO THEM TO
DETERMINE HOW THIS PILOT
PROGRAM IS GOING TO WORK. OKAY
THANK YOU- WHITE AND HE
DESERVES TO MOVE FORWARD AND
DESERVES TO I CONTINUE TO HAVE
THIS WORKED ON DIFFERENT
FACTORS WE DON'T- WE WANT TO
ACHIEVE THE GOALS IN THE END.
THAT WE CAN TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DO IT RIGHT SO THANK YOU FOR
ONE TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THOSE ISSUES ABSOLUTELY
NO AND I APPRECIATE- THE
SUGGESTIONS AND- I WILL
CERTAINLY. FOLLOW UP. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. COMMENTS
THERE'S MOTION BY MISS LEVINE
SEGMENTS RUBIO IT DOES HAVE A
TO PASS RECORDS TO NATURAL
RESOURCES FOR CLARIFICATION AND
DONE AT THIS TIME ATTORNEY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BUT
RESEARCHERS THAT. I WAS TOLD BY
STAFF THAT THIS WAS GOING TO GO
TO RULES AND THEN GO TO NATURAL
RESOURCES THE NEW JUST
CLARIFIED BY OUR COMMUNITY YOUR
CONSULTANT GO INTO. TO NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
FOR THE GIFT. ALL RIGHT THE
CALL QUESTION. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE EDUARDO GARCIA HI IN
ORDER GARCIA HI DOLLY DOLLY I'D
BEEN IT. SENATE NOT VOTING
BIGELOW BIGELOW I FRIEDMAN
CRISTINA GARCIA KALRA LEVIN
LEVINE AYE MURATSUCHI WHEN
RUBIO THANK RUBIO AYE SALAS
SMITH. SMITH I COULD DO IT VIA
TO DO I'D WARD WARD I. THANK
YOU POLITICAL OPEN- FOR OTHERS
TO ADD ON- AT THIS TIME I'M
GONNA SEE OF- THERE ARE ANY
INDIVIDUALS HERE WHO NEED TO
ADD ON TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AT WILL GO THROUGH THAT AND WE
WERE TRYING TO GET MR MCCARTY
HERE. TO PRESENT THE NEXT
PERSON WOULD BE OUR VICE CHAIRS
AND THEN YOURS TRULY WILL FOR
THE- SO WE'LL GO UP UP. TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR TO GET
EVERYONE ADDED ON. ABSENT
MEMBERS CRISTINA GARCIA KALRA-
SU CHI RUBIO RUBIO I SMITH. IT
THANK YOU. SMITH FIVE THANK YOU.
I THINK WE BELIEVE WE'RE
GETTING TRYING TO GET A HOLD OF
MISS MCCARTY. YEAH YEAH BUT-
THIS IS SALAS WOULD LIKE THAT
TO BE- LAST BILL THAT WE JUST
HEARD. HE THRILLED THREE AB
THREE OH THREE. AB THREE OH
THREE SALAS AYE. Q. OFFICIATE
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE. I MEAN FOR
THE BILL YEAH WE- UHHUH. ONE OF.
YEAH WE HAVE CENTER. SORRY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I'M HERE TO PRESENT B. B. TWO
TO THREE WHICH MAKES IT
UNLAWFUL TO TAKE DUDLEY A FROM
ITS NATURAL HABITAT ON LAND
OWNED BY THE STATE OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OR ON PROPERTY THAT
IS NOT ONE'S OWN AN ESTABLISHED
MINIMUM PENALTIES OF FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER PLANT FOR
THE FIRST OFFENSE AND FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER PLAN FOR
ANY SUBSEQUENT OFFENSES DUDLEY
IS A GENUS OF SUCCULENTS
INCLUDES FORTY SEVEN SPECIES
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SIX OF
WHICH CAN BE FOUND IN NATIVE
HABITATS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
RECENTLY THE GENUS BECOME
INCREDIBLY POPULAR AND IN SOME
OTHER COUNTRIES A SINGLE PLANT
TYPICALLY SELLS FOR A HUNDRED
DOLLARS OR UP TO A THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A LARGER DUDLEY A
PLANT AS A RESULT POACHERS HAVE
BEEN HARVESTING DEADLY BY THE
THOUSANDS TARGETING LARGER MORE
MATURE PLANTS ALONG
CALIFORNIA'S COAST AND SHIPPING
AND SELLING THEM ELSEWHERE
THESE LARGER PLANTS OFTEN TAKE
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED YEARS TO
GROW AND ARE UNLIKELY TO
SURVIVE FOR LONGER THAN ONE
YEAR WHEN REMOVED FROM THEIR
NATURAL HABITAT. POACHERS HAD
THE POTENTIAL TO MAKE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
PROFIT FROM W. HARVESTED IN
CALIFORNIA WHILE THE COURTS
HAVE BEEN CREATIVE IN
PENALIZING SOME POACHERS THE
FINE AMOUNTS THAT CAN BE LEVY
ARE MINUSCULE WHEN COMPARED TO
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY POACHERS
CAN MAKE SELLING THE PLANTS ON
THE ILLEGAL MARKET THE FAMILIES
ESTABLISHED THIRTY TWO TO THREE
OR ANALOGOUS WITH RECENT
LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS IVORY
AND SHARK FIN POACHING BY
EXPLICITLY MAKING UNLAWFUL TO
POACH DUDLEYA AND ESTABLISHING
STRONG PENALTIES FOR VIOLATIONS
AB TWO TO THREE WILL HELP DETER
DUDLEY APPROACHING AND PROMOTE
EFFCTIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT I HAD
NICK JENSEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY TO
TESTIFIED BY PHONE IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE PROCEED. EVERYONE CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES SIR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS NICK JENSEN AND I AM
THE CONSERVATION PROGRAM
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY FOR CAN'T
BE AT. MY REALIZATION OF THE
SPONSORED FOR A B. TWO TWENTY
THREE I WOULD LIKE TO OFFER OUR
SYRUP. THANKS TO ASSEMBLY
REWARD FOR CARRYING THE SPELL.
SAN BEEN VERY CONCERNED WITH
THE ISSUE ABOUT THE OPPOSED TO
PROTEIN. SINCE WE LEARNED ABOUT
IT ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO.
CALIFORNIA HAS TWENTY SIX
BECAUSE OF THE APPLET YOU'LL
FIND COVERING CLIFF FACES IN
COURT DESPITE THE BIKE I LOVE
US AND THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS. OUR STATE IS THE
CENTER OF THE DEADLY DIVERSITY.
AND POACHING ACTIVITY THREATEN
BOTH RARE AND COMMON SPECIES.
POACHERS HAVE REMOVED HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF PLANTS WORTH
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM THE
WILD AND SHOW NO SIGNS OF
SLOWING DOWN. I AM VERY
CONCERNED THAT THIS TREND COULD
DRIVE SOME BARBERIS PRACTICALLY
TOWARDS EXTINCTION AND GRAY AND
HABITATS WILL BE DEGRADED. MY
LIMITATION HAS RECEIVED
TECHNICAL INPUT FROM CDFW TO
HELP INFORM THE LANGUAGE
INCLUDED IN THE BILL. WE ALSO
ADDRESSED QUESTIONS FROM
INDIVIDUALS AND ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU. ABOUT HOW THIS BILL
WILL BE APPLIED. WE'RE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL ALONG WITH
THIRTY FIVE OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
AND OUR STATE BY CHAPTER
NETWORK OF ELEVEN THOUSAND
MEMBERS. EIGHTY TWO TWENTY
THREE GIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AND DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO TARGET
ILLEGAL POACHING OPERATIONS. IT
CLARIFIED THAT REMOVING THAT
THEY ARE FROM LAND CALIFORNIA
IS ILLEGAL WITHOUT LAND OF
LANDOWNER PERMISSION. OR A
PERMIT FROM CDFW. IT THOUSANDS
OF APPROPRIATE PENALTIES FOR
INTO OF THE INDIVIDUALS
CONVICTED OF HARVESTING W.
ILLEGALLY. THIS BILL IS A
NECESSARY STEP TO DETER FUTURE
POACHING OPERATIONS THAT
THREATEN CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
MARKHAM ABOUT DIVERSITY. FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT EIGHTY TWO
TWENTY THREE I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE THANK YOU THANK YOU WILL
MOVE ON TO. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
THAT ARE IN THE ROOM. I'D LIKE
TO SUPPORT THE BILL ANYONE.
CONFERENCE ROOM TO SEE THAT AND
ON THE PHONE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR. YOU AREN'T SUPPORT
OF THE BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE IF
THAT IS THE ROLE. AND WE HAVE
FIVE IN THE QUEUE RIGHT NOW WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOB ONE HAS
DROPPED SO WE WILL GO TO ONE
THIRTY SIX. GO AHEAD. HI ONE OF
THE MEAT ON A WITHOUT A LOT OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WE WILL GO TO MY NUMBER ONE
SIXTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
JENNIFER APPEARING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FISHING GAME
WARDEN SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO MY
NUMBER ONE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS CAN
DELFINO REPRESENTING DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
FORTY. THERE'S NOBODY ON THE
LINE WE DO NOT HAVE ANYMORE AND
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU. OUR
MODERATOR- WE WILL- BRING BACK
TO- WELL ACTUALLY WE HAVE TO
ASK ANYONE HERE IS AN OPPOSING.
AND OPPOSITIONAL MEASURE. WE
DON'T HAVE ANYONE SIGNED UP TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ANYONE IN
THE ROOM. NOW IN THE CONFERENCE
ROOMS WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE.
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN IS
ZERO. WE DO HAVE SOMEBODY
QUEUING UP HERE TO BE JUST A
MOMENT LIKE IT'S AN LINE NUMBER
THANK YOU. HEY WE HAVE. COMMENT
FROM THE LINE NUMBER ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE
UNFORTUNATELY HAD TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES AND WAS NOT ABLE
TO BE- ON SUPPORT BUT- ON
BEHALF OF THIS IS STEPHEN MYERS
ON BEHALF OF THE NET THE MENTAL
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. SORRY ABOUT THAT WHO.
THERE ARE ANY OPPOSING PLEASE
PRESS ONE EVENT ZERO. AND WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN Q. PERFECT
THANK YOU BRING BACK TO THE
BODY QUESTIONS COMMENTS IS OUR
MOTION. MOST READ MYSTERY PLOT
AND A SEGMENT VICE CHAIR. WHICH
I CLOSE THANK RESPECTFULLY ASK
DERIVE A THANK YOU- DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION GOES TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA
HI EDUARDO GARCIA I DALI DALI
I'D BENNETT BENNETT I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I FRIEDMAN STINA GARCIA
KALRA KALRA I. LEVINE
MURATSUCHI WHEN RUBIO RUBIO AYE
SALAS SALAS I SMITH SMITH I'D
BE ABLE TO DO IT VIA VIDEO AYE
WARD WORD I. THANK YOU WILLOW
ASK OUR NEXT PRESENTER SUMMER
MCCARTY. WE'RE GETTING VERY
CLOSE TO THE FINISH LINE
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. WELL HAVE MIGHT I
DON'T HAVE MY NOTES OR ANYTHING
BUT IT'S ALL GOOD RIGHT IS IT
YEAH I MEAN YOU SAID THIS IS A
AT THIS THIS IS A DISTRICT
BILL. ABOUT FLOOD CONTROL IN
SACRAMENTO AND YOLO IT'S A
DROUGHT RIGHT NOW THIS YEAR
WE'RE NOT THINKING ABOUT
FLOODING BUT BECAUSE YOU DON'T
KNOW SACRAMENTO'S THE MOST AT
RISK CITY IN AMERICA BESIDES
NEW ORLEANS. FOR FLOOD
PROTECTION AND THIS WOULD MAKE
SENSE- TECHNICAL CHANGES TO OUR
FEDERAL AUTHORIZATION. AND
ALLOW US TO BETTER COORDINATE
WITH FEDERAL AND STATE MONEY
FOR FLOOD CONTROL IN THE YELLOW
SACRAMENTO AREA SB RIVAL THANK
YOU TO HAVE A DO PASS.
RECOMMENDATION THE SAY HERE
THAT YOU HAVE TO WITNESSES AS A
BROWNING GREG FOLLOWED. PLEASE
PROCEED. AT MEDICARE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. ANY BROWN TO BE
HALF OF WHAT SACRAMENTO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DID GREAT
WITHOUT ANY NOTE. THIS IS A
BILL THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS
BEEN- SIMILAR TO LAST YEAR- IT
IT BASICALLY AUTHORIZES THE
BILL'S FEDERAL- NGUYEN ACT. AND
BASICALLY ADOPTED INTO STATE
LAW THIS DOES NOT INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IT JUST
FORMALIZES THE STATE
PARTNERSHIP IN THE CURRENTLY
AUTHORIZED PROJECT. THE BILL
WOULD ALSO RECOGNIZE CHALLENGES
TO PROTECT- DELIVERY CAUSED BY
THE COMBINED EFFECT OF KOBE.
THAT WOULD EXTEND THE PROJECT
DEADLINE TO TWENTY THIRTEEN
BECAUSE OF COVERAGE. AND THEN
SET THE SPECIFIC- DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THIS BILL AND WHAT YOUR
BILL IS THAT IT- WOULD ADDRESS
THE BOUNDARIES OF- RECLAMATION
DISTRICT NINE HUNDRED TWO
INCLUDED TERRITORY CONTAINED
AND A NEIGHBORING AREA
CONSOLIDATE THOSE EFFORTS AND
ALLOW. THE CITY OF WEST
SACRAMENTO- ELECTED OFFICIALS.
I SHOULD BE ON THAT BOARD THE
YOLO COUNTY LASKO HAS NOTED.
THAT IS OUR ABILITY TO CONTROL
TO DATE THOSE TO. AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FORGE PARK BOARD
IS CONSIDERING- THAT MADE ME
AREA AND TURNING UP IN THE
UPPER MAKE TO WEST ACKERMAN UP
LIKE CAN TO FILL. WE ASK FOR
YOUR BOATS DEAL BRAG FAVOR-
FROM THE FLOOD- THAT THE
PROTECTION DISTRICT AND- BUT
MANAGER FROM THE CITY OF WEST
FACTORED SIMPLY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
MAY HIGH AFTER I THOUGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE WILL- WE WANT
TO OTHER WITNESSES SINCE-
YOU'VE DEFERRED TO PUT THE
OTHER PERSON ON HOLD FOR
QUESTIONS. ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF MEASURE
THAT'S IN THE ROOM. SEE NO ONE
NO IN THE CONFERENCE ROOM I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY THERE- ON THE
PHONE LINE. CALLS IN SUPPORT
YOU ARE WHAT OKAY PLEASE
PROCEED. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE ONE
IN Q. HERE. THAT IS WHY NUMBER
ONE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI RYAN AND JACKIE AND REGIONAL
WATER AUTHORITY AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE I DO NOT SHOW ANYONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL BELONG TO OPPOSITION
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. I DON'T HAVE ANYONE
REGISTERED AS A WITNESS DO WE
HAVE ANYONE IN THE ROOM. ANYONE
IN THE CONFERENCE ROOM. ON THE
PHONE LINE. START OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THE END ZERO. AND I DO NOT SHOW
ANYBODY QUEUING UP FOR THE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'LL BRING YOU BACK TO THE BODY
ANY QUESTIONS ANY COMMENTS. DO
I HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE FOR A
BI. COPIER I MOVED ON SINCE YOU
SAID IT WAS ALL GOOD. A. B.
NINE TWENTY ONE. ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS WE HAVE A MOTION.
RIGHT THE MOTION OBSERVANT
SECOND. I'LL SECOND THE MOTION.
RIGHT RIGHT COMPANIES. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA I
EDUARDO GARCIA HI DOLLY.
DOLLING NOT VOTING BENNETT
BENNETT I BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT
VOTING FRIEDMAN CRISTINA GARCIA
KALRA. KALRA I. LEVINE.
MURATSUCHI NO WHEN RUBIO RUBIO
I. SALAS SMITH. SMITH NOT
VOTING VEHICLE DO IT VIA DUBAI
WARD WARD I. I WILL LEAVE THE
ROLL CALL OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON TAKING SOME
CARD. ALL RIGHT A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE WILL BE PRESENTING A
BILL VICE CHAIR MAKING DOLLARS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE'LL
START WITH AB ONE OF FIVE
SEVENTEENTH. EIGHTY FIVE
SEVENTEEN AS A SIMPLE BILL THAT
CLARIFIES LANDOWNERS
PARTICIPATE IN A SAFE HARBOR
AGREEMENT PROGRAM MUST RECEIVE
SEVEN BUSINESS DAYS NOTICE
INSTEAD OF JUST SEVEN DAYS
NOTICE WHICH IS WHAT CURRENTLY
AT THE STATE'S. AND DEPARTMENT
EFFICIENT LEVINE ACCESS THEIR
LANDS- I AM CURRENTLY IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
TO DETERMINE POTENTIAL POLICIES
THAT COULD HELP. INCENTIVIZE
LANDERS TO USE THIS PROGRAM AND
AB FIVE SEVENTEEN AS AND TENDED
TO ADVANCE THAT DISCUSSION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL OKAY.
YOUR VOTE SOME WITNESSES IT ONE
OF NOTE OKAY. NO WITNESSES
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. ON THE
PHONE LINE IT'S JUST CHANGING
THE DAY. THAT COULD BE IN THE
PORT OF THE BILL PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. I DO NOT SHOW
ANYBODY YET QUEUING UP RIGHT
NOW. THANK YOU. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. I HAVE NO WITNESSES
REGISTER TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ANYONE IN THE ROOM OPPOSING THE
BILL. NO IN THE CONFERENCE ROOM
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. THEY
ARE OPPOSITION OF THE BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE IF N. ZERO.
AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY IN
THE QUEUE. ALL RIGHT BRING
BACK- TO THE BODY AND OTHERS
MOTION MEMBERS RUBIO SEGMENTS
SET. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE
THANK YOU THIS HAZARD TO PASS-
TO APPROPRIATIONS THIS CALL.
THE MOST MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE DOLLY AYE
DOLLY AYE BENNETT. BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE FRIEDMAN CRISTINA
GARCIA KALRA KALRA I. LEVINE
SUU KYI AND WHEN RUBIO RUBIO
AYE SALAS SMITH. SMITH I'VE YET
TO DO IT VIA DUBAI WARD WARD I.
BENNETT I. COULD LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS AND I
WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR
SECOND FINAL BILL YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I AM HONORED TO
PRESENT AB EIGHT OH FOUR WHICH
WILL REDUCE FINANCIAL BARRIERS
AND INCREASE ACCESS TO OUTDOOR
SPORTS AND RECREATION FOR
CALIFORNIANS THIS BILL DOES TO
SIMPLE THINGS FIRST IT
CLARIFIES CURRENT LAW WHICH
ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE THE OPTION TO THAT
DESIGNATE TO FREE HUNTING DATES
PER YEAR. ONE IN THE FALL AND
ONE IN THE WINTER THIS WAS
ENACTED BY S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
NINE WHICH WAS PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN HOWEVER THE
DIRECTOR HAS NEVER ACTUALLY
DOESN'T NEED TO DAYS SO AB SO
AB EIGHT OH FOUR REQUIRES THE
DIRECTOR TO DESIGNATE. THOSE
DAYS SECONDLY THE BILL CHANGES
THE SEASONS FROM THE TWO FREE
HUNTING DAYS TO FALL AND SPRING.
UNDER AB EIGHT OH FOUR AN
UNLICENSED HUNTER WHO HAS
COMPLETED THE HUNTER SAFETY
COURSE THAT'S- VERY IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THEY'VE COMPLETED THE
HUNTERS GIVES SAFETY COURSE.
WOULD BE ALLOWED TO HUNT
WITHOUT A LICENSE ON THESE TWO
DAYS IF ACCOMPANIED. BY
LICENSED HUNTERS TWENTY ONE
YEARS OR OLDER WHO HAS HELD A
VALID HUNTING LICENSE FOR AT
LEAST THE LAST THREE
CONSECUTIVE YEARS. TO ENSURE
NECESSARY SAFETY IN THE FIELD
LICENSE MENTORS WOULD BE
RESTRICTED TO ONLY COMPANY ONE
UNLICENSED HUNTER AT A TIME.
AND THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
ALWAYS REMAIN AND CLOSE VISIBLE
AND VERBAL CONTACT WITH THEM.
THIS BILL CHANGES THE SEASONS
OF THE FREE HUNTING DAYS TO
SPRING AND FALL BECAUSE GAME
SPECIES IN THOSE SEASONS. ARE
IDEAL FOR NEW HUNTERS AS THEY
HAVE LOW BARRIERS TO ENTRY AND
MINIMAL. EQUIPMENT REQUIREMENTS
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WITH ME TODAY. WITH ME
TODAY TO- TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
ROY GRIFFITH WHO IS RETIRED
FISHING GAME WARDEN. AND ALSO
BILL GAINS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOMES BEEN FOR CONSERVATION
THANK YOU DO ENJOY DO PASS
RECOGNITION HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND FIRST WITNESS. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF ROY
GRIFFITHS BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AGAINST SOMEONE
SAID A RETIRED GAME WARDEN.
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS AS A GAME
WARDEN THE LAST FIFTEEN OF
WHICH I AROUND THE STATE'S
HUNTER EDUCATION PROGRAM.
HISTORY THE BILL AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SAID I'VE- BEEN INVOLVED
IN SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN- NO
SAFETY CORNERS HAVE BEEN CUT ON
THIS BILL AS MENTIONED. HUNDRED
DUCATION AND THE CLASSIFICATION
OF THE MENTOR OF ARE GOING TO
BE VERY CLOSELY WATCHED. THIS
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THE DECLINE OF HUNTERS IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES WE HAD OVER. SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND LICENSE
HUNTERS IN THE STATE NOW WE
HAVE LESS THAN THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND LICENSE UNDER THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT'S
ABOUT A 65% LOSS AND FIVE. FIVE
THOUSAND HUNDREDS A YEAR
BASICALLY BEING LOST FROM THE
STATE ALL THE TIME WHY WE HAVE.
UPWARDS OF THIRTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS GOING THROUGH HUNDREDS
OCCASIONALLY YEAR IN CALIFORNIA
WHICH BEGS THE QUESTION WHERE
THE SPOKES GOING WIRE TO GET IN
A HUNTING LICENCES. IT'S BEEN
CHAU THROUGHOUT THE NATION NOT
FINANCIAL COSTS ARE A BARRIER
TO GETTING NEW FOLKS INTERESTED
IN HUNTING. THIS IS JUST A
SMALL STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION OF GETTING FOLKS
INTERESTED GET THEM OUT THERE
THE TRY BEFORE YOU BUY IT IDEA.
HUNTERS ARE A CRITICAL TOOL IN
WILDLIFE MANAGEMENT CALIFORNIA
THEIR DOLLARS BRING IN HUNDREDS
OF THOUSAND DOLLARS IN LICENSE
FEES. AND APPLICATIONS TAGS
ALONE NOT TO MENTION. ALL LAST
YEAR ALONE ABOUT TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN PITTMAN ROBERTSON
DOLLARS ARE COMING TO
CALIFORNIA IT'S CRITICAL FOR
HABITAT USE EDUCATION SO FORTH.
AND AGAIN THIS IS NOT THERE'S
NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL OVER
ONE FIX FOR THIS BUT THIS BILL
IS A CRITICAL STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. OF THE R. THREE
MOVEMENT THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT READ TO RECRUIT RETRAIN
REACTIVATE THE NEXT GENERATION.
OF CALIFORNIA'S HUNTER
CONSERVATIONIST AND AS WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER THIS
COMMITTEE GAME MORE INTEREST
PRESS RELEASE FANS WE NEED LAW
ABIDING EYES AND EARS OUT IN
THE FIELD. HHONORS TURNED IN
ALL KINDS OF POACHERS EVERY
YEAR AND HELP. OUR GAME WARDENS
MAKE THE CASES SO- FOR ALL THE
REASONS REALLY. ALIVE OR THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT WITNESS REGULAR OF.
NUMBER MISTER CHAIRMAN CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK. THE OKAY. YES
PLEASE RIGHT. WE CAN HEAR YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BILL
GAINES AND TODAY I'M PLEASED TO
BE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING FOR
CONSERVATION. AND TWELVE OTHER
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT OH FOUR. TENURE
REVENUES DURING THE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL WILDLIFE FIVE HUNDRED
VIA THEIR PURCHASE OF HUNTING
LICENCES SAMSTAG ANOTHER
REQUIRED PERMITS PROVIDE
SUBSTANTIAL FUNDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT. TO CONDUCT PROGRAMS
ARE PROJECTS CRITICAL TO THE
HEALTH OF CALIFORNIA'S WILDLIFE
RESOURCES RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THESE ANNUAL
REVENUES TO THEIR WILDLIFE
MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES THE
DEPARTMENT IS CURRENTLY ENGAGED
IN A MAJOR EFFORT TO RECRUIT
RETAIN AND REACTIVATE HUNTERS
IN CALIFORNIA. THAT C. R. THREE
THAT MISTER GRIFFIN JUST FOR
TWO. SINCE NINETEEN NINETY ONE
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH WILDLIFE HAS AUTHORIZED
TO FIFTEEN DAYS AFTER
SUCCESSFULLY LED TO INCREASE
PARTICIPATION IN FISHING BY
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC. AND THE
ANNUAL REVENUES TO ANGLERS
GENERATE TO THE DEPARTMENT
FORFEITURE RELATED PROGRAMS AND
PROJECTS. SINCE TWENTY TWELVE
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL WILDLIFE HAS ALSO HAD
THE ABILITY TO AUTHORIZED TO
THREE HUNDRED DAYS BUT AS OF
TODAY THEY HAVE NOT DONE SO.
IT'S IMPERMANENT PRISON WITNESS
LEGISLATION WILL HAVE THE SAME
POTENTIAL POSITIVE EFFECT AS
THREE FIFTEEN DAYS AND INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF HUNTING LICENSES
AND RELATED PERMITS SOLD. IN
THE ANNUAL REVENUES THEY
GENERATE TO THE DEPARTMENT FOR
PROGRAMS AND PROJECTS THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO OUR STATE'S
WILDLIFE. ANOTHER POSITIVE
CHANGE EIGHT ZERO FOUR WOULD
MAKE TO EXISTING LAWS IT WOULD
CHANGE THE SEASONS OF FREE
HUNTING DAYS AUTHORIZED FROM
FALL AND WINTER TO SPRING AND
FALL. THIS CHANGES CRITICAL OF
HUNTING TURKEYS DURING THE
SPRING HUNTING SEASON WHICH IS
CURRENTLY ON RIGHT NOW. IS THE
BEST INTRODUCTORY GAME SPECIES
WITH LOW BARRIERS TO ENTRY
MINIMALLY CRIMINAL REQUIREMENTS
AND. RELATIVELY HIGH SUCCESS
RATES. IT'S ALSO WORTH NOTING
THAT ALTHOUGH THIS BILL IS LATE
AS- A DAYS LET'S JUST. THAT
PATTERSON BIT OF A MESS.
DEPENDING ON THE- THAT THE ON.
TO BE ON A LED. IT IS BUT FREE.
THE LEGISLATION REQUIRES THAT
ANY UNLIKE HUNDREDS PROTEST. IS
REQUIRED TO PURCHASE HAVING
THEIR- ANYWAY. DANCE STAMPS OR
OTHER PRINT. IN THE SUBJECT ARE
REALLY. PUT TO ALLOW. HUNTER
BURNING OUT A HOT LIQUID YOU
NEED HOW DO WE TO GO OUT OF
SUCCESS CAN BE COPPER. WHICH IS
LIKE WHY MAY IN. WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN HUNTING WILL TAKE
ON A SAFETY COURSE BUT. NOT
POSSESS THE HUNTING LICENCES.
NO PROGRESSIVE POP PLAYING. A
MENTAL TO TAKE DECENT IN THE-
OUT IN THE FIELD OF THEM WHERE
TO GO AND WHAT THE TO KNOW TO.
EXCEL PASSED IT INTO AB. WILL
ALSO PLAY A- INCREASE MY MORE
DIVERSITY IN. SIGNING. TO EIGHT
ZERO FOUR THAN AND CALIFORNIA'S.
LITTLE PIECES. DIVIDENDS TO OUR
STATE WILDLIFE. AND THERE HAVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON JERRY CARNAL-
RETIRED GAME WARDEN I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB YOU KNOW FOR THANK
YOU THANK YOU. SEE NO ONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM ANYONE IN THE
CONFERENCE ROOM DON'T SEE THAT
ANYONE THERE. ANYONE ON THE
LINE. MATTER MODERATOR. YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS THE ONE
ADVANTAGE ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE
TO IN THE QUEUE. WE HAVE ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE I CAPPING LANCE
REPRESENTING OUTDOOR
SPORTSMAN'S COALITION A
CALIFORNIA SPARKPLUG
INTERNATIONAL CALIFORNIA
CHAPTERS IN CALIFORNIA'S
PARKING BOBBY HALL IN FRONT OF
THE COURT AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU PERSONALLY FOR RUNNING A
VERY WELL OKAY COMMITTEE WAS
GREAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. AND I SPEAKER THANK
YOU THE NEXT ONE IS LINE NUMBER.
ONE FORTY THREE. HI MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MARKEDLY WITH CALIFORNIA WATER
QUALIFICATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE TWO
MORE IN Q. HERE WE HAVE MY
NUMBER ONE TWENTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON KELLY HOW CAN FOR THE
CONGRESSIONAL SPORTSMEN'S
FOUNDATION HERE TODAY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
KNOW I NUMBER. ONE SEVENTY
THREE. NUMBER ONE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR DOG ON THE
HOSPITAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYMORE IN SUPPORT ON THE
IN THE QUEUE PERFECT OPPOSITION
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ARAB ANYONE
REGISTERED AS A WITNESS. ANYONE
IN THE ROOM. NO ONE THE
TELECONFERENCING COULD SEE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. PINE
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO TO GET IN THE QUEUE.
AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY
QUEUING UP FOR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU TO HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
REPLIED MR SMITH I BELIEVE MIKE
CORRECT ON THAT ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
PLEASE TWO QUICK QUESTIONS JUST
WANT TO WITH YOUR RESEARCH ON
THIS AND AS THE AUTHOR OF HAVE
YOU COME UP WITH ANY REASONS
WHY DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND GME
HAS NOT BEEN DECLARING THESE
FREE DAYS NO THEY'VE HAD NINE
YEARS TO IMPLEMENT SO THIS BILL
BASICALLY MOVES FROM MAY TO
SHALL YOU WILL REQUIRE THEM TO
SET THE DAYS WOULD SAVE DONE IN
FISHING AND HAS RAISED THE
FISHING. LICENSES TO GO HAVEN'T
RESPONDED TO YOU IN ANY WAY IN
TERMS OF WHY THEY KNOW NOT TO
MY OFFICE NOW AND THEN FROM
FROM YOUR PERCEPTION WHO DO YOU
THINK WILL BE MOST TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF IT IS AT AN AGE
GROUP WHICH IS A CERTAIN-
CERTAIN TYPE OF- PERSON OUT
THERE IS IT WILL BE YOUNG
PEOPLE. WITH WHAT YOU
ANTICIPATE BEING A SPEAKING
FROM EXPERIENCE BOTH OF OUR
SONS HAVE BEEN THROUGH THE
HUNTER SAFETY PROGRAM AND THEY
BOTH ARE HUNTERS AND OUR
DAUGHTER IS ELEVEN AND SO I
DON'T KNOW THAT SHE'S GONNA I
DON'T KNOW THAT SHE'S GONNA
LOVE IT AND IT'S SO IT'S A
GREAT EXPERIENCE TO GET TO GO
OVER THESE TWO DAYS AND BEFORE
YOU INVEST IN ALL OF THE
EQUIPMENT AND THE TIME BECAUSE
SHE MAY NOT LOVE IT BUT SHE
MIGHT SUIT. I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY NEED
THE NEXT GENERATION WE'VE-
ENCOURAGING ARTS OUR CHILDREN
TO BE OUTSIDE THIS IS A GREAT
ACTIVITY WITH THE RIGHT MENTOR
WITH THE RIGHT PEOPLE IN YOUR
LIFE TO- HARVEST ANIMALS AND
LEGALLY SAFELY SO I THINK WE'LL
BE YOUNGER PEOPLE THAT USE THAT
HAVE SHE HIM FORM TO SPELL.
THANK YOU- QUESTION I WILL LAST
WEEK CALLED FOR OF DOES A DO
PASS. AS AMEND- TO BE A NATURAL
I'M SORRY. PUBLISHED COMMITTEE.
AND- WE DO HAVE A- SIR SO LOCAL.
THE MOTION IS FASTER PRO.
EDUARDO GARCIA HI EDUARDO
GARCIA HI DOLLY DOLLY I BENNETT
HI BENNETT I BIGELOW. BIGELOW
AYE FRIEDMAN. CRISTINA GARCIA.
KALRA LEVINE MURATSUCHI NO WHEN
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS SMITH
SMITH I'D BE A PRODUCER VIA
PODU I. WARD WARD I. WITH.
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR. OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON AND NEXT WE
HAVE AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED. BY A
CHANCE THANK OU MEMBERS
CHAIRED AND UP AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE-
THE CITY AFTERNOON OR EVENING
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU
ALL THE BE FIFTEEN HUNDRED A
SIX POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR
EVER SINCE THE BOND. THAT IS
DRAWING AUTHORED BY MYSELF AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN AND OVER
A DOZEN OTHER COLLEAGUES WHO
HAVE SIGNED ON IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE. WHETHER SMOKE
FROM WILDFIRES INCREASING
TEMPERATURES WATER RATIONING
BECAUSE THIS DROUGHT. THE NEW
TO PROVIDE SAFE CLEAN DRINKING
WATER FLOODING WHEN IT'S TOO
WET OR SEA LEVEL RISE WE ALL
KNOW. WHAT CLIMATE CHANGE LOOKS
LIKE AND ALL THE PARTS OF THE
STATE. THAT IS BECAUSE ALL OF
OUR DISTRICTS ARE EXPERIENCING
ONE OR MORE OF THESE IMPACTS
EVERY SINGLE DAY EACH YEAR THE
SITUATION BECOMING MORE URGENT.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES ARE FALLING
FURTHER BEHIND. AS YOU ALL KNOW
LAST YEAR WAS CALIFORNIA'S
WORSE FIRE SEASON. RECORD WITH
OVER FOUR POINT TWO MILLION
ACRES BURNED THIS IS ON THE
HEELS. THE RECORD FIRE SEASONS
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. THE
L. SEVENTEEN. WITH MULTI
MILLION ACRES OF BEING BURNED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THESE
FIRES IMPACT THE INTERSTATE
THROUGH WORSE. AND CONTRIBUTE
TO WORSE AIR QUALITY. EVEN WHEN
WE CAN'T SEE THOSE FLAMES.
LIKEWISE WE ARE ENTERING OF THE
DROUGHT AFTER RECENTLY
EXPERIENCING THE WORST DROUGHT
ON RECORD. AND WE HAVE THIS
CLIMATE CHANGE BOND PROPOSAL.
WOULD ENSURE THAT WE DRESS MANY
OF THOSE ISSUES. ALL THIS
SPEAKS TO WHY SB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED IS URGENTLY NEEDED THE
INVESTMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
BILL WILL MAKE COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA BETTER
PREPARED TO DEAL WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE. IMPACTS CALIFORNIA CAN
CONTINUE TO LEAD THE WAY. ON
RESPONDING TO CLIMATE CHANGE
AND AVOID THAT DIRE PREDICTIONS
THAT WE ALL HEAR ABOUT
CONSTANTLY. REPORTER WORKING
WITH ALL OF YOU AS THE BILL
MOVES THROUGH THE PROCESS. AND
ENSURE THAT ALL OF THE DIVERSE
NEEDS OF THE STATE ARE INCLUDED
I'VE HAD SOME GREAT
CONVERSATIONS WITH SOME OF YOU.
LOOKING FORWARD TO BROADER
DISCUSSIONS WITH ALL OF THE-
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
WILL. HAVE A DRINK OVER WITH
THE BAY AREA COUNCIL AND REGAL
MASTRODONATO WITH THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND ON THE LINE OVER.
HERE IN PERSON TO UP PROVIDES
INCOME SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR ATTENTION. MORE FROM
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
RICO MASTRODONATO WITH THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND AND I OF
COURSE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL- YOU
KNOW AT THIS POINT I DO.
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK THAT
VIRTUALLY EVERYBODY IN
CALIFORNIA KNOWS ABOUT FLYING
TO CHANGE- AND- AND I THINK IN
PART THAT'S BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN LEADING HE WAY ON
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE-
SINCE WELL WATER SINCE THE
BEGINNING. AND WHAT'S LESS
OBVIOUS IS OF THE BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
CALIFORNIA'S INVESTED.
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE ABOUT
90% OF THAT HAS BEEN SPENT ON
TRANSPORTATION AND ENERGY
PROJECTS AND- STRATEGIES- WE
NEED THIS BOND IT'S NOT COMING
THROUGH THE STATE- WE GOT SOME
MONEY THROUGH THE BUDGET THIS
YEAR BECAUSE OF THIS-
AFOREMENTIONED SURPLUS. BUT
TYPICALLY WE REALLY RELY ON
BONDS AND WE ARE VERY MUCH
RELYING ON A CLIMATE BONDTO
PASS THE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR.
THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LANDS- YOU
KNOW OUR EXPERTISE DISS
BUILDING PARKS AND WE WORK IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
MENTIONED. MANY OF THE-
SUBJECTS THAT THIS BILL IS
GOING TO ADDRESS I'M GOING TO
FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON HEAT. I
THINK THAT THAT IS A AREA THAT
THE STATE OF THEM WILLFULLY
IGNORING DESPITE ITS EMINENT
DANGER- AND WHAT SCIENCE IS
TELLING US- SCIENCE IS TELLING
US TO BUT- THE WORLD IS GETTING
CUT HOTTER. CALIFORNIA
CERTAINLY AS LAST YEAR WAS THE
HOTTEST YEAR ON RECORD AUGUST
THROUGH SEPTEMBER OCTOBER WAS
THE HOTTEST IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY WE HAVE TO NATURE BASED.
PROGRAMS THAT MITIGATE HEAT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA URBAN
FORESTRY AND URBAN GREENING
URBAN FORESTRY IS ZEROED OUT.
IN THE BUDGET URBAN FORESTRY IS
GETTING TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TEN FROM LAST YEAR AND
THIRTEEN FROM THIS YEAR. SO- AS
I MENTIONED HE DOES EMINEM WE
COULD HAVE A HEAT WAVE IN A
COUPLE OF MONTHS HE KILLS MORE
PEOPLE THAN ANY OTHER WEATHER
RELATED EVENTS CERTAINLY PUTS
MORE PEOPLE IN THE HOSPITAL AND
IT'S OUR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE I
WANT TO THANK. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA FOR ACKNOWLEDGING THIS
WITH THE HEAT CHAPTER IN HIS-
LEGISLATION. THERE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR AB THIRTY
ONE. THAT'S A LOCAL PARK
PROGRAM OBVIOUSLY THAT'S GOING
TO THAT PROGRAM IS FOCUSED ON
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES TO
QUALIFY FOR THE GRANTS SO IT'S
AUTOMATICALLY GOING TO GO TO
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND- YOU
KNOW INCOME. HIM GREEN SPACES
ENTRY CANOPY ARE BUT A
BASICALLY A 100% CORRELATION IF
YOUR HOUSEHOLD INCOME IS LOW
YOU DON'T HAVE GREEN SPACES YOU
DON'T HAVE TREE CANOPY AND ALSO
SOME OF THE HOTTEST PLACES IN
THE STATE. ARE IN LOS ANGELES
LAST YEAR THERE WAS A GROUND
SURFACE TEMPERATURE OF ALMOST A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DEGREES I
CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT IT WAS LIKE
AN ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA'S
DISTRICT. CALEXICO COACHELLA AT
CETERA. WE NEED TO DEAL WITH
THIS. WE ARE EXTREMELY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL. WE
SUBMITTED SOME AMENDMENTS.
BASICALLY TO INCREASE MONEY TO
ADDRESS HEAT- WE WANT TO
PRESERVE THE AB THIRTY ONE
MONEY BUT- OUR URBAN GREENING
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IT'S
OVERSUBSCRIBED JUST LIKE AB
THIRTY MONTH. MAYBE THIRTY ONE
HAD A SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR PER PROP
SIXTY EIGHT THEY GOT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IN
APPLICATIONS. SO AND URBAN
GREENING IS SIMILAR. THEY ARE
DIFFERENTLY FOCUSED URBAN
GREENING IS A MORE FLEXIBLE
PROGRAM THAT CAN. DO ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
AND SO ON- BUT THEY BOTH THE
CROPS IS SAME THING. MITIGATING
HEAT SO. LONG AND SHORT OF IT
IS AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
WE NEED THIS BILL. WE NEED TO
CONTINUE ADDRESSING WILDFIRES
WE HAVE EIGHT HUNDRED MILES OF
COAST. AGRICULTURE IS THE
NUMBER ONE BUSINESS. AND HE IS
COMING. AS GOING TO BE
EXTREMELY HAS ALREADY BEEN
HARMFUL. SO I URGE YOUR VOTE I
THANK THE MEMBER FOR AND THE
OTHER MEMBERS THAT ARE CO
AUTHORS. AND THE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU IN THE
NEXT WITNESS ON THE PHONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MALL AND ON BEHALF OF
THE LARGEST EMPLOYERS AND THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA. THE
DAIRY COUNCIL IS PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
ABOUT WITHIN THE PAST SEVEN
YEARS CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY
VOLATILE CLIMATE HAS SHATTERED
LONG STANDING CLIMATE RECORDS
RELATED TO DROUGHT WILDFIRE
HEAT. AND FLOOD EVENTS THESE
DISASTERS DAMAGED ECOSYSTEMS
DAY HER COMMUNITIES AND DISRUPT
AND TOO OFTEN COST LIVES. THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWELVE TO TWENTY
SIXTEEN DROUGHT FOR EXAMPLE
COST THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC LOSSES AND
NEARLY THIRTY THOUSAND JOBS THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WILDFIRES ALONE
COST. ALMOST A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS IN LOSSES
AND KILLED A HUNDRED THREE
CALIFORNIANS. THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FLIGHTS COST SEVENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN LOSSES
IN SAN JOSE ALONE AND NEARLY
TOPPLED THE OROVILLE DAM
EMERGENCY SPILLWAY. AND AUGUST
TWENTY TWENTY WAS THE HOTTEST
MONTH IN STATE HISTORY EXTREME
HEAT IS CAUSING INCREASED
NUMBERS OF PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFF OF THAT AND SWOLLEN
BLACKOUTS AND AVERAGING ABOUT
FORTY DEATHS EACH YEAR AS
INDICATED BY THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER. AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED
WOULD INVEST SIX POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN UPGRADING
AND IMPROVING THE RESILIENCE OF
CALIFORNIA'S NEIGHBORHOODS.
BUSINESSES INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ECOSYSTEMS THESE AND OTHER
CLIMATE RELATED CHALLENGES AND
IN DOING SO AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED
WOULD NOT ONLY HELP SAVE LIVES
AND AVOID COSTLY DAMAGES FROM
WILD FROM CLIMATE RELATED
DISASTERS. THAT WOULD ALSO HELP
CREATE JOBS STIMULATE GROWTH
IMPROVE ECOSYSTEM HEALTH AND
PROTECT COMMUNITIES. ACCORDING
TO ANALYSIS CONDUCTED BY THE
BAY AREA COUNCIL- EARLIER LAST
YEAR A BOND MEASURE OF SIMILAR
SIZE AND STRUCTURE- AB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED IT WOULD CREATE.
BETWEEN SEVENTY TO IN A TWO
FIVE JOB. AND GENERATE BETWEEN
NINE POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
AND FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
TOTAL ECONOMIC ACTIVITY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. PUTTING PEOPLE TO
WORK TO STRENGTHEN THEIR
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT IS AN
AMERICAN TRADITION GOING BACK
TO THE NEW DEAL. AND THE MOST
RECENT POLLING SHOWS A STRONG
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS WOULD
SUPPORT A CLIMATE RESILIENCE
BOND. THAT TIES TO JOB GROWTH
LIKE THIS ONE DOES THANK YOU
FOR TAKING MY COMMENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
ABOUT. THANKS WILL MOVE TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
CONFERENCE ROOM IN SUPPORT- IN
THE ROOM. MODERATORS CAN YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR SUPPORT.
ABSOLUTELY NOT THOSE ON THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. CAN ONE ZERO HERE
IN SUPPORT. AND IT LOOKS LIKE
WE DO HAVE ABOUT EIGHTEEN THAT
ARE CURRENTLY IN THE QUEUE. AND
WE'RE GOOD NO START WITH NUMBER
ONE SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS I'M
ABOUT ADVANCE WITH THE WIDENING
GROUP ON BEHALF OF BLOOM ENERGY
AND SUPPORT. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS STRANICA ON BEHALF OF
MY SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT I'M FINE
HOW TRAVEL PROBLEM LIMITED. NOW
WHAT THANK YOU. NOW GO TO
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JAMIE
MINOR ON BEHALF OF THE EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT SANTA
MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT
TURLOCK IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND
MP WE ARE AT THE PORT AMENDED
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE
MEASURE REPORT. I WILL NOW GO
TO NUMBER ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HEY FINAL PAYMENT ON
A WITHOUT AMONG CALIFORNIA.
RIGHT NOW THE NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MA'AM TURN MEMBERS
ROSS BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO AND SUPPORT
THE MEASURE THANKS. I WILL NEXT
BE ONE EIGHTY ONE NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON OR TOMORROW AT THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS OFFERING
SUPPORT IN CONTACT WITH THE
BILL- THE LEGISLATURE TO
CATHOLIC CLIMATE ONE HERE THANK
YOUNG. THE NEXT WILL GO TO
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JUST THE HIGHER WITH THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
WE THINK AUTHORS OR BRING IT
FORWARD IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
MEASURE AND WE HAVE A SUPPORT
AMENDED POSITION FOR THE
REASON. THAT LANDED OUR LETTER
THANK YOU SO MUCH. STE. NEXT TO
BE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI AUDREY
RETIRED CHECK FROM
CHRISTIANITY'S ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT WE'RE GOING
TO NUMBER ONE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI NATALIE BIRDS ARE
I ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION
CALIFORNIA HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANNING COALITION AND
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS. ALL IN
SUPPORT OF THE MANDATE AFTER
ARRIVING THERE SUBMITTED
LETTERS THANK YOU. SHE NEXT TO
BE NUMBER ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CURRENT
MEMBERS STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF
OF COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION
AND THEN CLICK REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT AND SAVE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE ALL IN SUPPORT
OF AMENDED AS DESCRIBED IN
THEIR SUBMITTED LETTERS THANK.
NEXT TO NUMBER ONE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
AGAIN THIS IS JENNIFER FEARING
AND THE CALIFORNIA MUSEUM HAS
THE SUPPORT OF AMENDED POSITION
S. THAT BOND WOULD YOU INCLUDE
FUNDING FOR PROJECTS TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S CULTURAL AND
HISTORICAL RESOURCES FROM QUITE
AN IMPACT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU. NOW GO TO NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
KNOW ABOUT THAT HIDING WITH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE A SUPPORT
AND DEMAND CONDITIONS AS
OUTLINED IN OUR LETTER THANKS
SO MUCH. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
ONE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAHTHIS IS MARK GENTLY WITH
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE A SUPPORT
WITH AMENDMENTS POSITION- WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE AN INCLUSION
OF FUNDING FOR DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL WILDLIFE WATERFOWL
HABITAT PROGRAMS WE APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. I
WILL NOW GO TO NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THIS IS JENNIFER
CLARY ON BEHALF OF CLEAN WATER
ACTION COMMUNITY WATER CENTER
STUFF UP ENTERPRISES LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE NETWORK PLANNING AND
CONSERVATION LEAGUE AND
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL PROJECT THIS
ACCOUNTABILITY. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE A SUPPORTED AMENDED
CONDITIONS THAT WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE INCREASE FUNDING
FOR SAFE DRINKING WATER IT WAS
RECOMMENDED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND WE REALLY LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHORS. FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE. NEXT
TO BE NUMBER ONE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON ERAPHS GONE WITH THE
MOUNTAINS RECREATION AND
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY I'D LIKE
TO SHARE OUR SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTED POSITION SHOULD
FUNDING BE MADE EQUIVALENT TO A
SIMILAR MEASURE IN THE SENATE
NONETHELESS THE BILL DOES
PROVIDE A GOOD FOUNDATION THANK
YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS JOSH QUICKLY WITH
SAVE THE BAY IN SAN FRANCISCO
JUST WANTED TO OFFER OUR
SUPPORT HI AND THANK MR GARCIA
MISTER MULLIN FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS THANK YOU.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MARTIN DOCUMENTS ON BEHALF OF
THE TREE CARE INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NOW WE'RE GOING TO NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS DOUG HOUSTON AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSTELLATION OF
CLIENTS INCLUDING EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICTS HERE
BUSINESS COUNCIL HERE
CONSORTIUM CALIFORNIA TAHOE
ALLIANCE CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR
RECREATION PARTNERSHIPS WERE
EXPRESSING. SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTY
FIFTEEN. ALL THREATENS BONDS
THAT PETITIONS. LA AND NORMAL
CARE PARKS BACK WITH THE VIEW.
M. THE CALIFORNIA PARK IN REX'S
THAT IF I COULD I THANK IN THE
COMMITTEES AND- TO THE AMEND
THAT ARE. THE AND NOW RECOMMEND
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THE WCW
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD OF
ENCOURAGED THE- THE JOINT
AUTHORS TO CONSIDER AN INCREASE
OF A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
IN SECTION. EIGHT OH FIVE TWO
FIVE. OR PER CAPITA BLOCK GRANT
THAT IS FOR WHICH DALY PROJECTS
IN URBANIZED SETTINGS. IN DOING
THIS THAT WILL ENSURE THAT THE
ALLOCATION FORMULA IS MORE
EQUITABLE FAIR. THANK YOU. THE
NEXT TO BE NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I NEED
ONE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE MAKE
SURE NOT ON MUTE. GOOD
AFTERNOON AFTER MEDIAN ON
BEHALF OF THE INTERROGATION
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT AND WE'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP IN ENSURING THAT
THEIR STRATEGIC INVESTMENT TO
ADDRESS ENVIRONMENTAL AND
SOCIAL ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND TO HELP
BUILD RECENTLY COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU. I AND- CHARGES
YOU'RE AWARE THAT WE STILL HAVE
NINE MORE IN THE QUEUE. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON COSTS AND THURMOND ON
BEHALF OF THE BIG SUR LAND
TRUST AND THE BOCA CHICA
LANDRAT WHO ARE IN THE PARK
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE A FEW
GROUPS THAT ARE SUPPORT AND
AMEND POSITION. AND THOSE ARE
AT CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF LAND
TRUSTS. CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF RETIRED CONSERVATION
DISTRICT SANTA CLARA VALLEY
OPEN SPACE THAT'S ALREADY THE
WILDLANDS CONSERVANCY AND THE
MOJAVE DESERT. LAND TRAT. AND
THE NEW CONSERVANCY HAS THAT
FEATURE. THEIR FOR EIGHTY HAD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT A
LITTLE ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
MA'AM JERRY MEMBERS ADAM YANIS
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCY- WE
HAVE A SMART SUPPORT AMENDED
POSITION ON AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED.
JUST WANT TO THANK A MEMBER
GARCIA AND MULLIN COULD THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE JUST
ALSO URGED THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD
ALLOCATE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
WATER RESILIENCE. THANK YOU.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
CALIFORNIA TAKING TIME AWAY TO
QUICKSTEP PORT IN A MAN FIRST
YUBA WATER AGENCIES FROM THE
DAM SAFETY FINDING COALITION
FACTORED AND SECONDLY EACH
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT WITH
STRONG SUPPORT AND A SMALL SIDE
OF A MAN ON THE SEPTIC TO SEWER
CONVERSION ISSUE THANK YOU.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ROSY COUNTENANCE METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA METROPOLITAN HAD TO
SUPPORT IN AMENDED POSITION AS
OUTLINED IN THE LETTER WE HAVE
AMENDED. AND AT ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS AS
WELL THEY HAVE COMMITTED AT THE
COURT AND THEN THE DECISION
MEDINA GOT. MY LETTER THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. WHEN I GO TO
LINE ONE NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS BATH A
LOT THOUGH ON BEHALF OF WATER
BE IS CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION-
ASKING FOR SIGNIFICANT MORE
FUNDING FOR MUCH NEEDED WATER
RECYCLING- TO HELP KEEP OUR
STATE RESILIENCE- AND SOME
PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES- THAT WE
HAVE SHARED WITH YOU AND YOUR
STAFF LOOK FOR TO FURTHER
DISCUSSION. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL MOVE TO NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CLICK ONE
EIGHTY NINE IS SET TO Q. WILL
MOVE TO NUMBER ONE NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON
HUMBLE SOLELY ON BEHALF OF FONG
ALREADY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN HUNDRED I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA FORCE CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP LEADERSHIP AND
COMMITMENT TO RESTORING
SOLVENCY THANK YOU. THANKS WE
GOT OUR NUMBER ONE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- CAN DELFINO ON
BEHALF OF THE NOBLE LAND TRUST
YOU IN OUR IN SUPPORT AND
EIGHTY FIFTEEN HUNDRED. I'M
ALSO REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY WHO
HAPPENS REPORT OFFENSIVE
POSITION AS IF I COULD SEE AN
INCREASE IN FUNDING PROFESSION
WILDLIFE HABITAT IN CHAPTER
FIVE AND SPECIFICALLY WHAT I
COULD BE. FUNDING ALLOCATED
FORGET THE CONSERVATION PROGRAM
AND ALSO WOULD JUST LIKE TO ADD
TO THE LAST SPEAKER- VERY-
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ALL OF THE STRONG.
SUPPORT FOR THIS POLICY FUNDING.
I WILL NOW GO TO NUMBER ONE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON RYAN ARE YOU CAN
REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY-
WITHOUT A SUPPORT IN AMEND
POSITION AS OUTLINED IN OUR
LETTER THANKS. AND NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER ONE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS A MAN
ARMED WITH A SHOULD COUNSEL
JUSTICE AND CONTROL ANY- I'M
GOING TO CREATION AND- SUPPORT
JUDGMENT KEY AMENDMENTS FOR
REASONS OUTLINED IN OUR LETTER
INCLUDING CAPITAL INVESTMENTS.
GOING TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU I DO NOT SEE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION LISTED.
WE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR ANY-
WANTING TO CALLING ON AND OFF
AND. ABSOLUTELY IN ANY- ANY
PARTISAN TELEPHONE LINE SECURE
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. WE DO HAVE ONE IN
THE QUEUE IT'LL JUST BE A
MOMENT. COOL. PUT ME. I DON'T.
WE DO HAVE ONE IN OPPOSITION
WILL GO TO LINE ONE NINETY. A
LINE ONE NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
A LINE ONE NINETY PLEASE MAKE
SURE NOT AND YOU. BOB GOOD
AFTERNOON MATTEO CROW ON BEHALF
OF PLASTER. YOU'RE ACTUALLY
THANK YOU. ALL ACTED AND THANK.
FOR LEADERS ARE OUR THANK YOU.
MMHM AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN THE QUEUE. PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WE LIKE TO BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE NOW FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. VERY
VERY BRIEF THREE QUESTION I
REALLY. LIKE MANY OF US IN A
PLOT THE AUTHOR FOR COMING
FORWARD WHICH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT- PIECE OF
LEGISLATION- WHAT THE CLIMATE
CRISIS OUT THERE WE ARE GOING
TO NEED A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES- AND WHAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE ABOUT THIS IS THAT
THE BOND WILL. ALLOW THE
ISSUANCE OF FUNDS TO CITY. ROSE
ORGANIZATIONS- IN PARTICULAR
THERE'S A JOINT POWER AUTHORITY
THAT'S ALREADY FORMED. THE
DEALING WITH THE TRYING TO
ATTEMPT TO DEAL WITH SEA LEVEL
RISE IN VENTURA AND SANTA
BARBARA COUNTIES- AND THIS BOND
WOULD DOES CERTAINLY HELP AN
ORGANIZATION LIKE THAT APPLY
FOR FUNDING. SO STRONGLY
SUPPORT DOESN'T THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I ALSO BELIEVE HE I HAVE
COMMITTED TO BEING A- CO
AUTHOR- WHETHER I'M ALREADY ON
OR NOT IF I WANT TO OFFICIALLY
DO IT TODAY IF I IF I'M NOT
THANK YOU. WELCOME THANK YOU
MA'AM CHAIR- WE'LL TAKE A BRIEF
MOMENT TO THINK- THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD.
IT'S NO SECRET THAT THESE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS ARE
CRUZ CRITICALLY NEEDED. EVERY
YEAR CALIFORNIA'S SEES A WHOLE
WARMTH OF CLIMATE CHANGE TAKING
PLACE. AS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN IN THE WORLD TOO
MANY PEOPLE DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO CLEAN WATER. AND DRINKING
WATER TOO MANY PEOPLE ARE
SUBJECT TO CLIMATE DISASTER. WE
CAN SIT BACK AND DO NOTHING
HOPING THAT THESE DAYS WILL
PASS WITH MINIMUM DAMAGE. IT
AND TURN A BLIND EYE OR
FLUORIDE WATER QUALITY IN
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES OR WE CAN
TAKE ACTION AND TAKE TAKE MORE
OF THESE INVESTMENTS BETTER TO
PREPARE TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES- I'M VERY THANKFUL
FOR THIS YEAR FOR TAKING THIS
ACTION AS THIS BILL. AND IF
IT'S OKAY WITH HIM I WOULD LIKE
TO COME ON AS A CO AUTHOR THANK
YOU LOTS OF PICTURES. OKAY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NICE ONES
THEY'VE CHAIR MISTER MULLIN FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AS WELL- LIKE
MR BENNETT I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT POTENTIAL HERE FOR
STRENGTHENING OUR RESPONSE FOR.
CLIMATE RESILIENCY AND WE KNOW
DOWN THE COMMUNITY LEVEL IN THE
IMPACTS THAT WE ARE FEARING FOR
BOTH OUR ENVIRONMENT OUR
ECONOMY MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO FIND- THE HIGH PRIORITY
PROJECTS THAT ARE NECESSARY FOR
OUR REGION'S WE HAVE TO GET
THOSE IMPLEMENTED SO I'M GLAD
IT'S GOING TO BE A SUBSTANTIAL
PART OF THIS BOND PROPOSAL-
ALMOST DONE OF MY DISTRICT WE-
KNOW THAT THE TRAGEDY TO
RECEDING IN THE TIJUANA RIVER.
ESTUARY AND THE BORDER PATROL-
SEE ME THE BORDER POLLUTION
CONTROL PROJECT THAT WE ARE
HAVING A CHALLENGE TO FULLY
FUND THERE AS WELL SO THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS- TOWARDS
IMPLEMENTING THAT MULTI BENEFIT
PRODUCTS TO PROTECT AND ENHANCE
THOSE BECAUSE THE RESOURCES IS
DEEPLY APPRECIATED. BY THE
COMMUNITY. IMPERIAL BEACH THANK
YOU FOR THE SUMMER. TO GARCIA.
HI THANK YOU I WANTED OUR MY
CALL- MY THE PRIOR FOR WORKING
THIS HE AND WORKING FROM WHILE
AND ADDS THAT THE GUY I'M
SUPPORT OF THIS TODAY AND AFTER
THIS GUY CONTENT I HOPE WE GET
A LOT OF AND- THE HEAT ISLAND I
AND HAD HELP MY THAT- BOTH
MITIGATE HOW TO HELP WITH THOSE
CONDITIONS- WE NEED TREES BUT
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE HEAT
BAKES IN A LOT OF POLLUTION-
THAT WE HAVE A MAKES IT THAT
MUCH MORE TOXIC AND SAYS WE'RE
DOING THIS RIGHT THAT WE'RE-
FAVORITE AT A WAY TO DEAL WITH
THE FOX X. IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES- SO THAT WE ARE A
LITTLE BIT SAFER. THE SAME
THING WITH THEIR SAFE DRINKING
WATER WE HAVE AN EMERGING
PROBLEM WITH P. FOSS OF EVER
CHEMICAL- AND A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES THAT KIND OF FOR
THE CLEAN UP- AND SO IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT SAFE DRINKING WATER
LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE THANK YOU
FOR COULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY.
FOR US TO CONTINUE TO ELEVATE
THESE ISSUES. IF ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OF THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS ASSEMBLY WHEN
GARCIA AND MULLIN WITH ALL THE
SUPPORT AMENDS IN SUPPORT IF
AMENDED. I LIKE TO PUT MY
AMENDMENT IN THERE IS MORE
WATER STORAGE AT WE NEED IN
CALIFORNIA EVERYONE KNOWS THAT
WE'RE HEADED RIGHT BACK INTO
ANOTHER DROUGHT RIGHT NOW. AND
WATER STORAGE IS GOING TO BE
THE KEY TO HELP US GET OUT OF
THAT. SO WHEN I WILL HOLD MY
VOTE I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU TO BRING THIS FORWARD
BECAUSE WE NEED WATER STORAGE
THE SCIENCE PROJECT. IN
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN GOING ON
FOR FIFTY YEARS WE NEED TO SEE
THAT PROJECT DONE THANK YOU.
CAN. ANY OTHER COMMENTS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN JACK CLOSE ALL CLOSE
WITH APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
BOTH THE POINTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE AS RELATES TO A POLICY
CONSIDERATIONS THE SUPPORT IF
AMENDED COMMENTS THAT YOU HEARD
THE TWENTY SOME PLUS REALLY IS
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL FOR YOU
MAKE SURE THAT WHAT WE WANT IS
IN THERE AND THE DIFFICULT PART
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT- AGAIN
WERE STRIKING THE BALANCE AND
MEETING THE GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES AND IF THEY
INTERSECT- THEN THERE'S A GOOD
CHANCE THAT THERE WILL BE SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL BE
REFLECTED. IN WHAT WAS BEING
ASKED FOR MAYBE A DISAGREEMENT
IN THE AMOUNTS BUT CERTAINLY-
THE POLICY- SHOULD REFLECT THAT
IF THERE'S AN INTERSECTION
BETWEEN THE EMISSION REDUCTIONS
CARBON SEQUESTRATION- AND OF
COURSE INVESTMENTS THAT COULD
ALSO LEAD TO SOME ECONOMIC
RECOVERY EFFORTS ON THE GROUND-
UTILIZING OUR CLIMATE CHANGE
EFFORTS SO I APPRECIATE THAT
THOSE COMMENTS DOES IT OF TIME
THEN THOSE WHO HAVE ADDED ON
TODAY AND I YOU KNOW OUR OFFICE
WILL CONTINUE WORKING WITH
EVERYONE. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE A PACKAGE
OF- THE CLIMATE CHANGE BONTA
THANK YOU AGAIN AND I CAN'T
THANK YOU ALL ENOUGH FOR YOUR
TIME YOUR PATIENCE TODAY- FOR
THIS HEARING. RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. I HAVE A MOTION- THANK
YOU CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO NET NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE. EDUARDO
GARCIA HI EDUARDO GARCIA HI
DOLLY NOT VOTING DOLLY NOT
VOTING BENNETT. BENNETT FIVE
BIGELOW FRIEDMAN CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA HI KALRA
KALRA EYED LEVINE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I KNOW WHEN RUBIO
RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS AYE AYES
SMITH. SMITH NOT VOTING WE HAVE
TO. VIA TO DO AYES AYE WARD
WARD I. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YEAH. SO WE'RE GOING TO START
AT THE TOP WE'LL START WITH THE
PROPOSALS- CONTENT CALENDAR FOR
FOLKS TO ADD ON AND THEN WE'LL
GO FROM ITEMS ONE THROUGH AND
ON CAN WE START WITH THE REAL
ADOPTION OF THE RULES YEAH WE
DO THAT OKAY ADOPTION OF THE
COMMITTEE RULES ABSENT MEMBERS.
CRISTINA GARCIA FIVE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I SALAS. SALAS I
SMITH SMITH I. DO A BIT OF A
DELAY I. CONSENT CALENDAR
ABSENT MEMBERS CRISTINA GARCIA
I'VE CRISTINA GARCIA BY CHOLERA
CHOLERA I MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
I. AB SIX FOURTEEN AGUILAR
CURRY. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT MEMBERS
BIGELOW. CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I KALRA KALRA I.
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I. AB
FIVE SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DOLLY DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN. CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I LEVINE
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I. NOYAN.
SALAS SALAS I. AB EIGHT OH FOUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY DO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I'D KALRA.
KALRA NOT VOTING. LEVINE
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I KNOW
WHEN SALAS SALAS I. AB THREE
SEVEN NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT MEMBERS
CRISTINA GARCIA. CRISTINA
GARCIA I'D KALRA KALRA I
MURATSUCHI MERCI GI. AB SIX
FOUR FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I KALRA KALRA I
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I. AB
EIGHT FIFTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER DO PASSED TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE ABSENT
MEMBERS CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I KALRA KALRA I
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I. AB
FIFTEEN HUNDRED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AT EDUARDO GARCIA MODE MOTION
IS TO DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE-
ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW
FRIEDMAN. LEVINE AND WHEN. AB
FIVE FOUR TWO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS TO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
ABSENT MEMBERS CRISTINA GARCIA.
AB FIVE FOUR TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS. CRISTINA
GARCIA I KALRA KALRA I'M
MURATSUCHI MERCI GI. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE FIVE FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT
MEMBERS CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA NOT VOTING.
KALRA IT'S AB FIVE FIVE FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
COLORANT NO MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI NOW. AB NINE TWO ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY DO
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS. THE
ABSENT MEMBERS OF FRIEDMAN
CRISTINA GARCIA HI CRISTINA
GARCIA I LEVINE. RCG MURATSUCHI
I NO WHEN SALAS SALAS HI THE
BILL IS OUT. AB TWO FIVE TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIVAS THE PASTOR
PREPARATIONS. ABSENT MEMBERS
CRISTINA GARCIA. CRISTINA
GARCIA I KALRA KALRA I'D
MURATSUCHI MERCY GI. AB THREE
OH THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS DE PASSED TO NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE ABSENT
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN. STINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I'D KALRA.
KALRA NOT VOTING. MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI NOT VOTING NO WHEN.
AB TWO TO THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARD. THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I. LEVINE
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I KNOW
WHEN. RIGHT. THANK YOU EVERYONE.
WE ARE ALL DONE. HAVE A NICE.
ONE THE MANAGER YEAH.